SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO AN ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. UH WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE Ó STREET BUILDING
ROOM. 2200 I WILL ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE COME TO
BE PRESENT SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING
. UM I ALSO ASK FOR ANY AUTHORS,
UM, THAT ARE GOING TO BE HEARD
HERE TODAY TO COME FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN GET DOWN TO
BUSINESS. WE HAVE 11 BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, AND TWO OF THOSE
ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT. SO
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
OF OUR BILLS, LET US ESTABLISH A
QUORUM TODAY. ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL OUR ROLL. ALVARADO GILL
PRESENT. ALVARADO GILL PRESENT.
CæA BOGUE. HERE A TO BOGUE HERE.
BLAKESPEAR BLAKESPEAR HERE.
MENJIVAR. MANJAR HERE. WAHAB. WE
HAVE A QUORUM PRESENT. UM THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UH, WE WILL WE HAVE
TWO BILLS ON PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEM. FIVE SENATE
BILL 1000 THREE 122 AND FILE
ITEM SIX. SENATE BILL 1440 THREE
TO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO REMOVE
BILLS FROM OUR CONSENT. YEAH.
OK, WE WILL NOW TAKE UP BILLS ON
CONSENT. WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU.
MOVED BY. SENATOR MENJIVAR
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN SYNC CALENDAR. ALVARADO GILL
HØI ALVARADO GIL I A èC B A èC
BOG EYE. BLAKESPEAR BLAKESPEAR
EYE MENJIVAR MENJIVAR I WAHAB
THANK YOU. ALRIGHT UH, VOTE IS
FOUR AND OH MOVES THE CAR. RIGHT
THANK YOU. SO LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS. I SEE SENATOR ROTH IN
THE AUDIENCE AND WE WILL HEAR
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SENATE BILL
1249, SENATOR ROTH WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MADAM.
CHAIR MEMBERS, UM THIS BILL
SENATE AT 1249 SEEKS TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
RAPIDLY AGING POPULATION BY
MODERNIZING CALIFORNIA'S OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT. SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL PROPOSES TO REFORM THE
Ó èC TO CONFORM TO RECENT
CHANGES IN FEDERAL REGULATIONS,
WHICH IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
OLDER AMERICANS ACT AND
INTRODUCE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES, UPDATE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES AND
ESTABLISH TIME FRAMES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING
TO ENGAGE IN STAKEHOLDER. BY
2031 IN FOUR CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE AGED 60 OR OLDER. THIS
DRAMATIC DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT, AS
WELL AS THE CHANGING NEEDS OF
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
REQUIRES THAT WE RE EXAMINE HOW
THE CURRENT SYSTEM DELIVERS
AGING SERVICES. THIS SYSTEM WAS
BUILT IN SILOS WITHOUT AN EYE
TOWARD PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE.
TODAY WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTEGRATING HEALTH
CARE, SOCIAL SERVICES, HOUSING
AND TRANSPORTATION, ALL OF WHICH
ARE CRITICAL TO MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OLDER ADULTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AGING SERVICES DO NOT
AND SHOULD NOT ANY LONGER BE.
HANDLED IN A SILO FORMAT.
CURRENTLY AGING SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED BY 30 THREE AREA AGING
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING, A
COVERING ALL 58 COUNTIES. THE
NETWORK WAS FIRST PUT IN PLACE
NEARLY 50 YEARS AGO, WHEN THE
OLDER ADULT POPULATION WAS, IN
FACT, MUCH SMALLER AND LESS
DIVERSE, AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, THERE ARE NÓ
DEFINED CORE SERVICES THAT AN
AREA AGENCY ON AGING MUST
PROVIDE. NOR ARE THERE ANY
METRICS TO TRACK THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE SERVICES.
THIS HAS LED TO A PATCHWORK OF
INCONSISTENT SERVICES THAT DOES
NOT FULLY SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
RAPIDLY GROWING OLDER POPULATION
. THIS BILL MODERNIZES AND
STRENGTHENS THE SYSTEM,
PROVIDING SERVICES TO OUR AGING
POPULATION. IN THE FOLLOWING
WAYS ONE IT CAN FORMS THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT TO THE FEDERAL
OLDER AMERICANS ACT, ENSURING
OUR STATE IS IN FULL COMPLIANCE.
TWO IT REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO DEVELOP
ON OR BEFORE SEPTEMBER, 2026 IN
CONSULTATION WITH AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING AND STAKEHOLDERS. KEY
NEW PROVISIONS, INCLUDING A
PERFORMANCE MEASUREMENT,
METHODOLOGY, CORE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES OF FUNDING FORMULA AND
A STATEWIDE ENGAGEMENT PLAN. TO
IMPROVE OUTREACH TO
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
APPROPRIATE CASES AND IN
ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS. IT GIVES COUNTIES
THE OPTION STARTING IN JANUARY,
2025 TO PETITION THE DEPARTMENT
TO ASSUME CONTROL OF THE AREA
AGENCY ON AGING THAT SERVES THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION WHERE SUCH
CONTROL WOULD PROVIDE COUNTIES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER
INTEGRATE AGING PROGRAMS WITH
OTHER COUNTY PROVIDED SERVICES.
SUCH AS ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH,
VETERAN SERVICES, AMONG OTHERS.
THIS WOULD INVOLVE AN EXTENDED
PROCESS WITH SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AND INPUT AND A
TRANSITION PERIOD AT A MINIMUM
PRIOR TO ANY CHANGE. THERE IS NÓ
ON AND OFF SWITCH. THE FULL AND
FAIR PUBLIC PROCESS WILL ENSURE
THAT ANY ACTION TAKEN WILL ONLY
BE TAKEN IF IT IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OLDER ADULTS TO DO
SO. THE INTENT IS TO ENSURE THAT
CHANGES, IF ANY, WILL BE NOTICED
WITH ADEQUATE TIME DUE PROCESS
AND APPEALS AGAIN. ITS CORE
SENATE BILL 1249 FOCUSES ON
ENSURING THAT OLDER ADULTS
RECEIVE THE MOST CO ORDINATED
CARE DELIVERED BY THE ENTITY
THAT WOULD SERVE THEM THE BEST.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT
ADDRESSES THE OPPOSITION LETTER
THAT THE COMMITTEE RECEIVED
FAIRLY RECENTLY. WITH THAT, AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I WOULD
REQUEST AND I VOTE. I AM PLEASED
TO HAVE HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE
SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL 1249,
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT COMMISSIONER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
ELLEN SLING, AS WELL AS MY
CONSTITUENT AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE ON
AGING JULIE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO LEAD WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IT FROM
THESE TWO WITNESSES FOR A TOTAL
OF TWO MINUTES EACH. UM, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING FORWARD.
I'LL HAVE YOU, UH, STATE, YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION. UM
PRIOR TO BEGINNING I'M ELLEN
SCHMID AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING.
I'M JULIE AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
FOR RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE ON
AGING AND AREA AGENCY IN AGING.
OK SORRY ABOUT THAT, JULIE. I
THINK OUR MICROPHONE WAS OFF
THERE. UM WE'LL WE'LL BEGIN WITH
YOUR COLLEAGUE HERE FIRST. AND
THEN WHEN WE GO TO YOU, WE'LL
HAVE YOU. UH, REPEAT, THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M ELLEN
SMEEDING, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON AGING
AND THE IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT
AND A CURRENT COMMISSIONER, AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1249
. THIS IS SPONSORED BY SENATOR
ROTH. AS YOU KNOW, I HAVE 28
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND WORKED
AS THE FORMER CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER WAS ST PAUL'S SENIOR
SERVICES AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
AAA IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. IN THAT
ROLE IN THOSE ROLES, I'VE SEEN
THE PRESSING CHALLENGES THAT ARE
FACING OLDER CALIFORNIA. AND
THEY REQUIRE A NEW WAY OF
THINKING CHALLENGES WE HAVE,
LIKE HOUSING, HOMELESSNESS,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND INCREASING
RATES OF ALZHEIMER'S AND
DEMENTIA. SB 1249 WILL MODERNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S NETWORK OF AGING
SERVICES, SOMETHING I HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR MY ENTIRE CAREER
TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE ACCESS TO CONSISTENT, HIGH
QUALITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS BUILT ON
YEARS OF STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT,
RESULTING IN OUR MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING THE STATE'S 10 YEAR
BLUEPRINT. IN 2022, THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING CONVENED KEY
AREA AGENCY ON AGING AND COUNTY
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING THE
COMMISSION TO LAUNCH THE
CALIFORNIA 2030 INITIATIVE. MORE
THAN 200 STAKEHOLDER. INTERVIEWS
WERE HELD WITH ALL 33 AAA S¼ IN
THE STATE PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROCESS. THIS BILL RESPONDS TO
THE 2030 FEEDBACK AND PROVIDES
TIMELY RECOMMENDATIONS, OUR
CURRENT PLANNING AND SERVICE
AREA BOUNDARIES WERE LAST
ADJUSTED IN THE LATE SEVENTIES,
WHEN THE STATE'S POPULATION OVER
65 WAS JUST 10% AND THE MAJORITY
OF OUR ELDERS WERE WHITE
CAUCASIAN. WE NOW HAVE A
DEMOGRAPHIC IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE
THE CURRENT DIVERSITY OF
POPULATION IS REFLECTED IN THE
SERVICES WE PROVIDE. THIS BILL
RESPONDS TO NEW FEDERAL
REGULATIONS THAT DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY CORE
SERVICES. CREATE PERFORMANCE
METRICS FOCUS ON THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
NEED AND DEVELOP POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT AFFIRM THE
CRITICAL ROLE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IN PROVIDING AGING
SERVICES. WE'RE ON A TIME FRAME.
THESE CHANGES HAVE TO GO INTO
STATE LAW BY OCTOBER, 1ST 25. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR ROTH
FOR PRIORITIZING OLDER ADULTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES BY ALTERING
S¼ B 12. 49 AND I ASKED THE
COMMITTEE FOR AN I VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MOVING TO OUR SECOND WITNESS AND
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS JULIE LEE, DIRECTOR OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE ON AGING
AND AREA AGENCY ON AGING. RIGHT?
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JULIE AGAIN DIRECTOR OF
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE ON
AGING. I AM PLEASED TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1249,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH
MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS A
LOCAL AAA DIRECTOR. THE AGING
POPULATION IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
IS GROWING FASTER THAN ANY OTHER
REGION IN THE STATE AND WITH
MORE COMPLEX HEALTH AND SOCIAL
NEEDS THAN EVER. WE SAW THESE
COMPLEXITIES PLAY OUT DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS WE STRUGGLED WITH
ENORMOUS CHALLENGES TO DELIVER
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN
ISOLATION DUE TO LANGUAGE, RURAL
LOCATIONS AND MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. THESE ADVERSITIES
PUSHED US OUR AAA TO OUT OF OUR
COMFORT ZONE COMPELLED US TO BE
AGILE AND TO FIND SOLUTIONS.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. OUR LEADERSHIP
HAS PRIORITIZED THE ONE COUNTY
SERVICE IN IRATION APPROACH
MODEL A MODERNIZATION FOR OUR
AREA AGENCY ON AGING. AS A
RESULT, WE NOW HAVE A MUCH
DEEPER PARTNER POOL THAT
INCLUDES HUMAN SERVICES, HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND FIRST RESPONDERS
WORKING TOGETHER TO FIND
UPSTREAM SOLUTIONS. CORRIDOR AAA
SUSTAINING THE EVOLUTION
PARTNERSHIP AND INNOVATION IS
HARD FOUGHT FROM THE PANDEMIC.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE SERVED
APPROXIMATELY 100,000
INDIVIDUALS LAST YEAR, THIS IS
MERELY SCRATCHING THE SURFACE.
FOR THESE REASONS. WE ARE
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO SENATOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR
FOCUS ATTENTION ON THE AGING
POPULATION. WE EMBRACE THE
CHANGES PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
AND WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
EQUALLY IMPORTANT OUR EFFORTS TO
BREAK FUNDING SOURCES AMONG
STATE PROGRAMS SO WE CAN OPEN
DOORS MORE DOORS FOR SENIORS WHO
ARE HOMELESS, MEDICALLY FRAGILE
OR AT AN ECONOMIC BREAKING
POINT. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES,
UH, IN SUPPORT, UH, ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC COMING TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE WITH YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY,
PLEASE. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF
OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
TONY GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE HOME
CARE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HØI JASON GAFFAR ON
BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, YASMIN
PELET ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND
AGING IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEBBIE METER WITH
THE COMMISSION ON AGING AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HØI
GOOD AFTERNOON, HEATHER HARRISON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF OF
ALZHEIMER'S L, A ALZHEIMER'S
ORANGE COUNTY AND ALZHEIMER'S IN
ALZHEIMER'S SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I WILL HEAR TWO WITNESSES FOR TO
TWO MINUTES AND ASK YOU TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
TABLE. YOU MIGHT WANT TO STAY
JUST IN CASE WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
YES. YEAH, OK.
OK? THANK YOU FOR COMING FORWARD
. WE'LL HAVE YOU, UM, SIT AT THE
MICROPHONE. UH, STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION, PLEASE. BEFORE
WE BEGIN. THAT THAT YOU JUST
KEEP TALKING? YES. CLAY CAMP,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SENIORS COUNCIL WAS WHICH IS THE
AAA OF SANTA CRUZ AND SAN BENITO
COUNTIES. THANK YOU. WILL TIFT
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AREA FOUR
AGENCY ON AGING NEVADA, PLAIR,
SACRAMENTO, SIERRA SUTTER, YOLO
AND YUBA COUNTIES. THANK YOU, OK
, YOU CAN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. TWO MINUTES, PLEASE.
WE'RE IMPROMPTU SPEAKERS. WE DID
NOT KNOW WE WERE GOING TO
REPRESENT THE GROUP. THERE'S
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE HERE VOICING
THEIR OPPOSITION AS WELL. UM, A
COUPLE OF THINGS. UM I'M THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF TRIPLE A'S IN
THE STATE RIGHT NOW. I'VE BEEN
IN THIS ROLE FOR ABOUT 25 YEARS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
I'M MOST CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT
JP, A S¼ AND Tð AND NONPROFITS
HAVE BEEN THE INNOVATORS IN
AGING SINCE THE ONSET OF THIS,
AND THERE'S FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
HAVE THAT COUNTY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS DON'T HAVE. SO WE
EMBRACE LOOKING AT THE MAP AND
LOOKING AT POTENTIAL CHANGES,
BUT WE ARE CONCERNED THAT IF
ANYTHING, THE BILL DESPITE ITS
GOOD INTENTIONS, IS HAVING THE
COUNTER EFFECT OF REALLY
PROMOTING INNOVATION AND LETTING
THAT HAPPEN. SO THAT'S OUR
BIGGEST CONCERN, AND WE THINK
THAT IS TIED INTO THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO SET
STATEWIDE PRIORITIES IN AGING.
THAT'S TOTALLY BACKWARDS FROM
INNOVATION. THE WAY INNOVATION
HAPPENS, AND WHAT HAPPENS NOW IS
LOCAL AGENCIES HAVE CONTROL OF
THE DOLLARS THAT COME IN, AND WE
MEASURE WHAT THE NEEDS ARE IN
OUR COMMUNITY, LOOKING AT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A RURAL
COMMUNITY AND AN URBAN COMMUNITY
. THE DIFFERENCES ARE VAST, AND
IT'S REALLY ONE OF THE BEAUTIES
OF THE FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS
ACT. IT'S SOMETHING US IS
CHAMPIONING IN THE
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE NEW OLDER
AMERICANS ACT, AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT'S NOT LOST IN
THIS PROPOSAL. THIS PROPOSAL
DOES TAKE THAT AWAY. UM GIVEN
WHAT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE UP A
WHOLE LOT OF TIME, BUT THERE'S
TWO REALLY IMPORTANT PARTS THAT
I THINK ARE KIND OF OVERLOOKED.
BESIDES THAT LOSS OF LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY, AND IT'S KIND OF
CASUALLY MEASURED IN THE BILL
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WILL REVISE THE INTERSTATE
FUNDING FORMULA THAT WILL NOT BE
AN EASY TASK. THE WHOLE FORMULA
CAME ABOUT WHEN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING WAS ACTUALLY
SUED TO CREATE ONE AND WHAT
HAPPENED AFTER THAT WAS A SERIES
OF LAWSUITS AND LEGISLATION TO
KIND OF MAKE IT FINAL. THOSE
TOOK 10 YEARS TO RESOLVE IT
STARTED IN 1990. WHEN I FIRST
BECAME A DIRECTOR IN 2000, IT
WAS STILL THE LAWSUITS AND LEGAL
ACTION WAS STILL RAGING ON SO I
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP, OK, I WILL.
SO PLEASE DON'T BURDEN. UH, THE
LAST SIX YEARS OF MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING WITH THIS AND THEN MY
FINAL COMMENT, UH, THIS IS THE
MELLOW GREMLIN ACT, AND SENATOR
HENRY MELLO WAS A CHAMPION OF
AGING, AND THIS ACT WAS HIS
PRIDE AND JOY, A FRIEND OF MINE
WHO WORKED FOR HIM RECENTLY SAID
THEY'RE GLAD HENRY'S GONE
BECAUSE IF HE SAW THIS
LEGISLATION, IT WOULD KILL HIM.
I THANK YOU. WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUR SECOND WITNESS. TWO MINUTES,
PLEASE. OUR OUR OBJECTION TO
THIS BILL IS REALLY CENTERED
AROUND THE LANGUAGE THAT
COUNTIES WILL HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ASSUME CONTROL OF THE
EXISTING AGENCY ON AGING IN
THEIR JURISDICTION. THIS IS
PREJUDICIAL TOWARDS COUNTY
GOVERNANCE. IT ASSUMES THAT ANY
COUNTY IS MORE CAPABLE OF
ADMINISTERING AN AGENCY ON AGING
, REGARDLESS OF THEIR SIZE,
THEIR EXPERIENCE THEIR
RESOURCES. IF COUNTY GOVERNANCE
WAS THE ANSWER, THEN WHY DON'T
WE HAVE INSTEAD OF TWO OF OUR
RICHEST COUNTIES REPRESENTED
HERE IN SAN DIEGO AND RIVERSIDE,
EL DORADO COUNTY AND IMPERIAL?
IF THIS IS THE VIEW THAT THIS IS
WHAT EQUITY LOOKS LIKE THAT
IMPERIAL SITTING NEXT TO SAN
DIEGO THAT WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT
THERE. THOSE ARE COUNTY BASED
AGENCIES ON AGING AND THEY'RE
STRUGGLING GREATLY. WE OPERATE
HISTORICALLY AT 10%
ADMINISTRATION. COUNTIES OPERATE
AT 30% OR HIGHER ADMINISTRATION.
WE CAN GET SOMETHING ON OUR
AGENDA IN 30 DAYS OR LESS. OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM COUNTY BASED
TRIPLE A'S THREE MONTHS OR
LONGER, WE'RE THREE TIMES FASTER
OR THREE TIMES CHEAPER. HOW DOES
THIS BILL BENEFIT? THE PUBLIC.
IT DOES NOT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'LL NOW GOING TO INVITE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION
WISHING TO BE HEARD TO COME TO
THE FRONT MICROPHONE AND SHARE
THEIR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY. OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MEGAN ROSE WITH
LEADING EDGE CALIFORNIA WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL OPPOSED
POSITION, BUT WE DO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND ITS
IMPLICATIONS ON SERVICE. CO
ORDINATION IN RURAL COUNTIES
SPECIFICALLY, SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS ON SOME SAFEGUARDS
THERE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OK?
THE NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY, PLEASE. MY NAME
IS ANISA DELP ALL I'M HERE
REPRESENTING SOURCE WISE 501
NONPROFIT, UM, DESIGNATED AS THE
AREA AGENCY IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HØI JAMIE SHARMA, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE FRESNO MADERA
AREA AGENCY ON AGING, AND WE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. HØI KRISTEN MILLHUFF,
DIRECTOR OF AREA 12 AGENCY ON
AGING THAT REPRESENTS ALPINE,
AMADOR, CALAVERAS, MARIPOSA AND
TUOLUMNE COUNTIES. AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
SARAH MARTINEZ I'M A REGIONAL
SERVICE SPECIALIST WITH AGENCY
ON AGING AREA FOUR. AND WE
OPPOSE THIS, BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, JOE
COBER, DIRECTOR OF PASSAGES,
PLANNING AND SERVICE AREA THREE,
REPRESENTING BUTTE, COLUSA, GLEN
PLUMS AND TO HIM COUNTIES. WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. OK? WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION TO THE
MEMBERS, ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
ASK QUESTIONS OR MAKE ANY
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME? SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR. UH, YES, I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS
IN THE F. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR. UM IN THE FIRST
PLACE. WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING FEDERAL
ACTION IN A FEDERAL SET OF
REGULATIONS. UH, REMEMBER, THESE
PROGRAMS REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN
REVIEWED IN WHAT 50 YEARS IN THE
WAY WE'VE STRUCTURED THEM. UM
WITH RESPECT TO COUNTIES
ASSUMING CONTROL, REMEMBER, THE
BILL GIVES THE COUNTIES THE
OPTION TO PETITION TO HAVE THEIR
REQUEST TO ASSUME AREA AGENCY ON
AGING FUNCTIONS CONSIDERED AND
THERE'S A FULL PROCESS BUILT OUT
IN THE BILL OR WILL BE BUILT OUT
IN REGULATIONS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS FULLA ON THAT ISSUE. MY
RECOLLECTION FROM THE ORIGINAL,
UM LANGUAGE OF YEARS AGO IS
COUNTIES HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
OPT IN, BUT IT WAS WITHIN IT WAS
WITH RESPECT TO NEW PROGRAMS,
NOT WITH RESPECT TO EXISTING
PROGRAMS. SO THIS EXTENDS THE
COUNTY. UH, OPPORTUNITY TO
REQUEST THROUGH A PETITION THE
ABILITY TO OPT IN WITH AN
EXISTING PROGRAM NOW I WOULD SAY
THIS NOTHING IN THIS BILL FORCES
OR REQUIRES THAT THERE BE ANY
CHANGE IN THE WAY IN THE WAY
THESE AREA AGING SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED WHETHER IT'S BY
NONPROFITS, JOINT POWERS,
AUTHORITIES OR WHATEVER WHAT IT
DOES, UH, HOPEFULLY BRING ABOUT
IS A REVIEW OF THE WAY WE'RE
DELIVERING AGING SURFACES
BECAUSE THINGS MAY HAVE CHANGED
MAY HAVE CHANGED IN PARTICULAR.
COUNTIES MAY HAVE CHANGED UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND THIS WILL
ALLOW THERE TO BE A REVIEW OF
THE WAY WE'VE DELIVERED SERVICES
IN THE PAST. AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE MAKING THESE DECISIONS, THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE TO DECIDE
WHETHER WE CAN BETTER INTEGRATE
THOSE SERVICES WITH THE OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE IN THE STATE. AS I
INDICATED BEFORE I HÌ S¼ S¼
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES,
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES, MANY
OF WHICH ARE ADMINISTERED AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. SOME THROUGH
CONTRACTS, SOME DIRECTLY BUY BY
THE COUNTY AND LASTLY, TO
RESPOND TO THE INNOVATION PIECE.
THE LAST THING ANY OF US WANT TO
DO IS TO STIFLE INNOVATION. BUT
I BELIEVE AND PEOPLE HAVE HEARD
ME SAY THIS BEFORE IN OTHER
SETTINGS, YOU KNOW, IN THE
MILITARY, WE SAID, WHAT GETS
WHAT GETS MEASURED GETS DONE. I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO DEVELOP A
SERIES OF PERFORMANCE METRICS
WITH INPUT FROM THE PUBLIC FULL
TRANSPARENCY AND OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO COME
IN AND EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS AS WE
DEVELOP THIS SET OF PERFORMANCE
METRICS TO MEASURE WHAT IS BEING
DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
WHETHER IT MEASURES UP SO TO
SPEAK TO THE POLICIES THAT WE
SET AT THE STATE. FEDERAL LEVEL
WITH RESPECT TO THE WAY OLDER
ADULTS ARE TREATED, HANDLED AND
SERVICED. SO JUST TO PUT THE PIN
ON IT. THIS IN NÓ WAY
DISCOURAGES OR STIFLES
INNOVATION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
BECAUSE, FRANKLY, AT THE END OF
THE DAY IF THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE THE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING, LET'S ASSUME THEY'RE
NONPROFIT ARE DELIVERING EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED. AS A RESULT OF
THIS REVIEW, THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT SHOULD CONTINUE IN THE
FUTURE. THERE'S NÓ PREDETERMINED
RESULT HERE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ROTH ANY OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
TO ASK QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THANK YOU, SENATOR OJA. I DO
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
CLARIFICATION. UM SENATOR ROTH?
UM I WILL ALSO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE OPPOSITION OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION LETTER CAME IN FAIRLY
LATE. UM AND SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ONE THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE HERE TO, UM TO SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS ARE HEARD. I ALSO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THERE'S A PROCESS
FOR US TO EVALUATE THESE FAIRLY
AND TO BE ABLE TO DISCUSS THEM.
UM, SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. WE WILL
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THESE, BUT
OUR GOAL IS TO PUSH FORWARD
POLICY THAT IS NOT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL. BUT THAT WORKS FOR ALL AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT CALIFORNIA IS
A VERY DIVERSE STATE. I FOR ONE
REPRESENT 13 RURAL COUNTIES. UM
AND UNFORTUNATELY, YOU KNOW THIS
. THIS LETTER THAT WE RECEIVED
KIND OF LATE IN THE GAME WAS MY
FIRST AWARENESS OF OPPOSITION
FROM RURAL COMMUNITIES ON THIS
BILL, SO THAT TELLS ME THAT WE
HAVE A GAP IN COMMUNICATION. SO
I I'M LOOKING AT AT AT SOME OF
THE, UH, THE ISSUES THAT ARE
BROUGHT UP IN THIS LETTER OF
OPPOSITION. I AM CONFIDENT THAT
SENATOR ROTH, THE AUTHOR HAS
ADDRESSED THOSE AND HAS BEEN
MINDFUL OF THOSE. I WILL SAY
THIS THAT IN LOOKING AT THE
LETTER OF THIS POLICY, THERE IS
AN OPTION FOR THE COUNTY TO
ENGAGE AND TAKE CONTROL AND THAT
FOR ME IS LOCAL CONTROL, GIVING
THE COUNTIES THAT ABILITY TO
CHOOSE TO DO SO IN LOOKING AT
THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND LOOKING AT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR, UH,
THEIR CONSTITUENTS, THEIR
DEMOGRAPHICS. I THINK ALL OF
THAT FOR ME IS VERY IMPORTANT.
UM BECAUSE I TEND TO NOT SUPPORT
ONE SIZE FITS ALL POLICY. UM,
BEING THAT MANY OF THE COUNTIES
THAT I REPRESENT. THE OPPOSITION
IS IN THE ROOM TODAY. UM I'M
GOING TO PONDER ON THIS ONE. BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THAT THIS IS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE THAT IS HEARING
THIS. UM, IF WE ARE TO PASS IT,
IT WILL GO TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE
AND I HAVE FULL FAITH THAT THE
AUTHOR WOULD BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION IN ENSURING
THAT OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
HURT. THANK YOU. SENATOR ROTH
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. WELL, I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
PATIENCE HERE. UM LET ME JUST
SAY THIS. THE BILL AND THE LAW
REQUIRES. UM THE èC Dð A TO
CONSULT WITH THE AREA AGENCIES
ON AGING AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO
DETERMINE WHAT NEXT STEPS ARE
TAKEN. SO THERE IS GOING TO BE
ABSOLUTE TRANSPARENCY, CLEAR DUE
PROCESS AND THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION BEFORE ANYONE
MAKES ANY DECISION IN ANY WAY,
AND I CAN JUST REITERATE, UM, IN
PARTICULAR IN THE RURAL COUNTIES
IN THE COUNTIES IN THE NORTH AND
SOME TO THE IN THE CENTRAL AND
PERHAPS NOW, WHERE I COME FROM,
UM, COUNTIES MAY FIND THEMSELVES
WOEFULLY UNPREPARED TO TAKE ON
THESE TASKS, BUT WE STILL NEED
TO HAVE THE REVIEW PROCESS. SO
IT VERY WELL MAY BE THAT THE
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING THAT I'M
SURE ARE DOING A SPECTACULAR JOB
UP AND DOWN THE STATE CONTINUE
TO DO THAT VERY SPECTACULAR JOB
AND WITH SOME PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT ARE BUILT IN AND
MAYBE MAYBE SOME INTEGRATION
IMPROVEMENT WITH THE OTHER
SERVICES THAT THE COUNTIES DO
PROVIDE, SO IT IS NOT MY INTENT
TO UNDERMINE OR DO AWAY WITH ANY
NONPROFIT. OR ANY OTHER AREA
AGENCY ON AGING THAT IS
PERFORMING SERVICE IN IN THIS
STATE, BUT WE DO NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
FEDERAL LAW AND REGULATION AND
THIS BILL, AND WE DO NEED SOME
PERFORMANCE METRICS TO MEASURE
WHETHER WHAT'S BEING DONE
MEASURES UP TO WHAT WE EXPECT AS
A STATE AND WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT EXPECTS AS A STATE AS
A RESULT OF THE MONEY PROVIDED
WITH RESPECT TO SERVICES TO OUR
OLDER ADULTS. OFTEN THOSE WHO
ARE MOST VULNERABLE, WHO NEED
OUR HELP THE MOST. SO WITH THAT
AGAIN, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR
FOR YOUR PATIENCE RESPECTFULLY.
AS FOR AN I VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WAHAB. UM, THE
MOTION IS TO AND IT WAS I RIGHT
TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM THREE
S¼ B 1249 DO PASS TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL HØI
ALVARADO, GAIL IAB. BLAKESPEAR
BLAKESPEAR I MENJIVAR MENJIVAR I
WAHAB WAHAB. I OH, THAT BILL
MOVES TO CALL. UM I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY AGAIN. UM THIS
BILL WILL BE HEARD AGAIN IN
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION. I AM
ALSO A MEMBER OF THAT COMMITTEE.
SO I PLEASE ENCOURAGE THE
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR. OK, THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU. UM, I
SEE SENATOR DE RAZA. OH I SEE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. HELLO SENATOR
GONZALEZ. WE WILL MOVE FORWARD
NOW, WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE SENATE
BILL 1016, SENATOR GONZALEZ.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I AM HERE TO PRESENT S¼
B 1016, WHICH WILL HELP UNCOVER
TRENDS AND DISPARITIES THAT ARE
OFTEN HIDDEN IN AGGREGATED
HEALTH DATA FOR LATINOS AND
INDIGENOUS MESO AMERICANS.
LATINOS MAKE UP 40% OF THE GOOD
STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION. HOWEVER WITHIN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY, THERE ARE
SEVERAL ETHNIC GROUPS THAT HAVE
DIVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES. THESE
DISTINCTIONS HIDE IN THE
MONOLITHIC TERM OF LATINO WHICH
LEADS TO LESS DETAILED AND
NUANCED HEALTH INFORMATION. SB
1016 WILL ADDRESS THE
SHORTCOMINGS BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO COLLECT AND RELEASE
DISAGGREGATED DATA FOR SPECIFIED
LATINO SUBGROUPS, INCLUDING
MEXICAN SALVADORAN, GUATEMALAN,
EACH MAJOR MESOAMERICAN
INDIGENOUS NATION AND OTHERS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE DONE TO
THE API COMMUNITY. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY, I
HAVE MARVELOUS WITH THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND ANTONIO, UH
ANTONIA WITH COMUNIDADES IN DÍAS
AND LISCO CIELO. UH, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON S¼ B 1016. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, AND WE
WILL HEAR FROM EACH OF YOU FOR
TWO MINUTES EACH AND PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. UM AND WHEN
YOU'RE READY, PLEASE GO. GO,
PLEASE GO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS MARVELL, DIRECTOR OF
POLICY WITH THE LATINO COALITION
FOR A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. THE US
CENSUS BUREAU RECENTLY REPORTED
THAT OVER ONE IN FOUR AMERICANS
ARE LIKELY TO BE LATINO BY 2060.
WITH OUR GROWING POPULATION, IT
IS CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA THE
STATE WITH THE LARGEST LATINO
POPULATION AT 40% UNDERSTAND THE
DIVERSITY AND SPECIFIC HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY. THIS IS
WHY L èC èC IS A CO SPONSOR OF
SB 1016, AUTHORED BY SENATOR
LENA GONZALEZ, WHICH WILL
COLLECT AND DESEGREGATE
ANONYMOUS DEMOGRAPHIC AND
LANGUAGE DATA FOR LATINX
SUBGROUPS AND INDIGENOUS
MESOAMERICAN NATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE GOAL OF SB 1016
IS TO UNCOVER AND REDUCE
UNDERLYING HEALTH DISPARITIES,
BOTH CLINICAL AND THOSE RELATED
TO SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
, SUCH AS HOUSING FOR LATINO AND
INDIGENOUS NATIONS. IN
CALIFORNIA, RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
MORE SPECIFIC HIGH QUALITY
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS BENEFICIAL
TO ADDRESS AND EFFECTIVELY MEET
THE HEALTH NEEDS OF DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. LATINOS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE MULTIPLE
UNDERLYING CHRONIC CONDITIONS
LIKE ASTHMA AND DIABETES. MORE
SPECIFIC DATA COULD ALLOW PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS TO CULTURALLY COMPETENT
AND RESPONSIVE CARE AND
INFORMATION TO ADDRESS THESE
DISPARITIES. CALIFORNIA MUST
ALSO START COLLECTING SPECIFIC
DATA FOR INDIGENOUS MESO
AMERICAN NATIONS IN CALIFORNIA,
WHO DO NOT IDENTIFY AS LATINO
AND WHO SPEAK MORE THAN 560
LANGUAGES. DURING THE PANDEMIC,
INDIGENOUS MESO AMERICANS WERE
ALSO DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
AS MANY ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
SUCH AS FARM WORKERS, BUT FACE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS TO ACCESS
TIMELY AND RELIABLE HEALTH
INFORMATION ON COVID AND ON LIFE
SAVING VACCINES. S¼ P 1016 WILL
COLLECT DATA ON MESER INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES, WHICH WILL ASSIST IN
INCREASING EQUITABLE ACCESS AND
UTILIZATION OF HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
LIKE HOW FRESH B 1016 HIGHLIGHTS
AND BRINGS AWARENESS TO OUR
UNIQUE AND DIVERSE DIFFERENCES
AND ENSURES HEALTH EQUITY FOR
INDIGENOUS AND LATINAS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
FOR S¼ B 1016. AND MY COLLEAGUE.
UH ANTONIA WILL, UH, PROVIDE HER
TESTIMONY IN SPANISH AND I CAN,
UH, INTERPRET, WHICH IS THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE, UM, IN P
CONO TAISTO, CAN YOU. NOT KEEP
ITS BUENAS STARES? MIRE ANTONIA
VELASQUEZ, MAYA INTERPRETED THE
LID MACHE DE COMMUNES. LOS
ANGELES, CALIFORNIA DEO
LINGUISTIC, PARAN DÍAS, IRAN IN
CALIFORNIA LENTO, ESTADOS
UNIDOS, NOR GUO COPAIN DE LÀ EVE
GONZALEZ TENER DATOS
DEMOGRAPHICS ES I DE LÀ ALTA
CALIDAD ES PITAL SER LÀ
NECESIDAD, THE SALUTE DE LAB IN
CALIFORNIA. CONTRIBUTION A
ECONOMIA DEO. PORQUE CREQUE
PUEDEN CARGO PUBLICA II LO DESU
CON MAJOR STATE THAT PORQUE NÓ
HANG UP 10. MASO TAMBIÉN LÀ DE
DURANTE LÀ PANDEMIA DEL COIN
NUEVE COMORES PUESTA CIELO
INICIO ARE RECOIL. I INDITA AND
THE LOS ANGELES AND THE CONDA DE
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA IT'S THE
INFORMACIÓN PERMITE, POR NÓ SE
PUEDA SUMER TO LOS DEL SUR DE LÀ
FRONTERA, A ESPANOL SONG LATINOS
PORQUE BANG LÀ COMUNIDAD IN
SEROUS, NOOS AND ABSOLUTO.
RESPITE WAS MENTAL. LIO SOTO, A
DE LÀ A DE LÀ ESAS SO GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS ANTONIA
VELASQUEZ, MAYA QUICHE,
INTERPRETER OF THE QUICHE
LANGUAGE FROM COMIDAS, INDIGENAS
AND RACO, ALSO KNOWN AS CIELO,
BASED IN LOS ANGELES. THAT
ADVOCATES FOR LINGUISTIC RIGHTS
FOR INDIGENOUS MIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. CIELOS A PROUD
COSPONSOR OF S¼, B 1016.
AUTHORED BY SENATOR LENA
GONZALEZ. HAVING SPECIFIC HIGH
QUALITY DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS
VITAL TO MEETING THE HEALTH
NEEDS OF INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA WHO CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR STATE'S ECONOMY. I HAVE
INTERPRETED SITUATIONS WHERE
MOTHERS ARE AFRAID TO APPLY FOR
CAL FRESH BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
THEY MAY BE A PUBLIC CHARGE AND
THAT THEIR CHILDREN WILL PAY THE
CONSEQUENCES LATER. AH BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT OBTAIN THE CORRECT
INFORMATION IN THEIR NATIVE
LANGUAGES. WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
REQUEST INFORMATION AND AN
INTERPRETER. IN OUR LANGUAGE.
THEY ARE HUMAN RIGHTS. WE ALSO
SAW THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT
HAVING INFORMATION IN OUR
LANGUAGES DURING COVID-19 THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC. IN RESPONSE,
CIELO BEGAN COLLECTING DATA
WHICH CONFIRMED 17 INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES SPOKEN AND LIVING IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THIS
INFORMATION ALLOWED US TO
DELIVER THE BEST SERVICE TO
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES. LASTLY
YOU CANNOT ASSUME THAT EVERYONE
WHO COMES FROM SOUTH OF THE
BORDER SPEAKS SPANISH OR THAT
EVERYONE IS LATINO BECAUSE IT
ERASES INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES.
WE DO NOT EXIST. IF WE DO NOT
EXIST IN NUMBERS, WE DO NOT
EXIST AT ALL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I VOTE FOR S¼ B 1016. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UM WE'LL NOW HEAR
FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL, PLEASE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE. STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY
PLEASE. REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW,
POVERTY AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. JOHNNY
PINEDA ON BEHALF OF THE LATINO
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND MORE MORE THAN 40
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF SB 1016. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED CO WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SUSANNA
KNIFFEN WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
SNYDER WITH CAPITOL ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ WITH THE
MESSA GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. YASMIN
PELLA ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE AND
AGING AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OK WE WILL
NOW MOVE FORWARD TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION? RIGHT èC
N ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL? SEE
NONE. I MOVE THE CONVERSATION
BACK UP TO THE MEMBERS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. MANJAR. THANK YOU
FIRST. I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS UP. UM
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES FOR STATING THE
REASONS WHY THE COMMENTARY ABOUT
IF YOU DON'T EXIST IN NUMBERS,
UM YOU DON'T EXIST AT ALL IS
VERY TRUE. AS AS A AS I OFTEN
SAY, I'M A MINORITY AMONGST
MINORITIES, UM, FALLING IN THE
ASIAN CATEGORY, BUT LARGELY
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN ANYTHING. UM, IN
FACT, OUR NUMBERS GET DILUTED.
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS MARK WHITE, NOT OF
CAUCASIAN DESCENT. UM OTHER
ASIAN AND SO MUCH MORE. UM, SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS VERY
MUCH NEEDED, ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED SERVICES AND ARE OFTEN
OVERLOOKED BECAUSE THE LARGER,
BROADER COMMUNITY IS POTENTIALLY
DOING WELL. SO FOR EXAMPLE, I
OFTEN SPEAK ABOUT IT IN THE
SENSE OF YOU KNOW IF WE TALK THE
BROADER ASIAN COMMUNITY, UH WE
ALL COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND
POTENTIALLY HAVE DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES AND CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
WE LIVE IN. UH, SOME OF US MAY
HAVE YOU KNOW, FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT HAVE COME TO THIS COUNTRY
OR LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY WITHOUT
BEING LITERATE WITHOUT, YOU KNOW
, SPEAKING ENGLISH WITHOUT ANY
FORMAL EDUCATION WITHOUT A
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS, WHILE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE BROADER
COMMUNITY COULD POTENTIALLY COME
HERE ON A WORK VISA BE FULLY
SUPPORTED BY FINANCIALLY, UH,
HAVE A JOB SET UP HAVE YOU KNOW,
UH DIFFERENT TYPES OF VISAS SET
UP AND SO FORTH, SO I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES TO GET
DEEPER DEEPER INTO THE
COMMUNITIES. UM SO I FULLY
APPRECIATE THIS BILL. I FULLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT THIS
NEED. UM AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MANJAR. THINK
SENATOR HOBB IS GOING TO MOVE
ALL THE BILLS. I THINK SO, TOO.
SHE'S GONNA BEAT US. DID SHE? A
GUEST ON OUR GUEST? RIGHT OK,
SPECIAL GUEST. UH SENATOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD. IN FACT, JUST A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO. OUR WELL,
YOU HAVE A LONG BEACH PUBLIC
HEALTH. BUT KENS PUBLIC HEALTH
CAME OUT WITH THEIR NEW SURVEY
RIGHT AND IT GAVE THREE
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHICS BLACK,
ASIAN AND LATINX INTO THE
SENATOR'S POINT, THEY SAID. THEY
SAID THAT THE ASIAN AMERICANS AS
A WHOLE HAVE BETTER HEALTH
OUTCOMES. BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BREAKING IT DOWN BY EACH
SUBCATEGORY. AND UNDER LATINX.
THEY JUST GROUP ALL LATINX AS A
WHOLE. AND YOU KNOW YOU AND I
BOTH KNOW THERE'S LITTLE COUNTRY
IN CENTRAL AMERICA THAT IS OFTEN
FORGOTTEN, RIGHT EL SALVADOR,
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
INCLUDE ALL DEMOGRAPHICS. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. THANK YOU. AS
YOU KNOW, I HAVE DEEP AFFECTION
FOR SALVADORIANS. SO YES. THANK
YOU. UM THANK YOU. UM SENATOR,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I JUST
WANT TO THANK OUR SPECIAL GUEST
AND OUR, UH, GOOD SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR THEIR COMMENTS,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, UH,
SENATE BILL. UH 1016 HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WAHAB,
ASSISTANT POLICE CALL THE ROLL.
HIGHLIGHT ITEM ONE S¼ B 106. DO
PASS TO HEALTH COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GAIL. I AL FOR GI A èC
B¢O. BLAKESPEAR BLAKESPEAR EYE
MENJIVAR MENJIVAR I WAHAB WAHAB?
AYE. 40 THAT BILL MOVES TO CALL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. WILL MOVE FORWARD
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL
1107, THEN DUO WHEN YOU ARE
READY SEE WHAT THE PODIUM YOU'RE
WELCOME. DO YOU HAVE ANY MEMBERS
WITNESSES HERE TODAY? IF YOU DO,
THEY CAN COME AND GO AHEAD AND
SIT DOWN HERE AND THAT'LL GET US
GOING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND, UH, MEMBERS, UH, I FIRST
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF, UH, FOR WORKING
WITH OUR STAFF ON THIS
LEGISLATION, AND I COMMIT TO
TAKING THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
WILL NARROW THE DEFINITION OF
GOVERNMENT RELATED MAIL. S¼ B
1107 WILL PROVIDE FOR UNHOUSED
CALIFORNIANS TO RECEIVE AND PICK
UP THEIR GOVERNMENT RELATED MAIL
AT A COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES OFFICE. CURRENTLY
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES RELY ON THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE TO
DELIVER IMPORTANT MAIL TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO, UH, WITHOUT A
RELIABLE MAILING ADDRESS THROUGH
GENERAL DELIVERY. THIS FREE
SERVICE PROVIDES ACCESS TO MAIL
DELIVERED TO A LOCAL POST OFFICE
DESIGNATED AS A GENERAL DELIVERY
, AND THAT COULD VARY FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY. FOR EXAMPLE,
SAN FRANCISCO HAS ONE GENERAL
DELIVERY POST OFFICE AS AN
ALTERNATIVE CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
A PERMANENT ADDRESS, HAVE ALSO
RELIED ON RECEIVING THEIR MAIL
AT COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES OFFICE
OFFICES IN SOME LIMITED COUNTIES
SAN BERNARDINO, SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELUS. YOU COULD SEE FROM
VARIOUS SIZES. CALIFORNIANS TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC BENEFITS RECEIVE
NOTICES AND ACCESS OF SERVICES
THROUGH THE MAIL. INCLUDING THE
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER
CARDS, RECERTIFICATION OF PUBLIC
BENEFITS AND NOTICES OF HOUSING
PROGRAMS AMONGST OTHERS. NOTICES
FOR THESE DOCUMENTS OFTEN
REQUIRE PEOPLE TO RESPOND IN A
TIMELY MANNER. IF NOT THEIR
BENEFITS OR SERVICES COULD BE
INTERRUPTED OR CUT OFF.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE SERVICES ARE
OFTEN UNRELIABLE WITHOUT SET
RULES AND STANDARDS, AND THEY
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO UNHOUSED
PEOPLE HAVING NÓ OR VERY LONG
DELAYS TO RECEIVING THEIR
SERVICES. NOT SOMETHING THAT, UM
WE CAN AFFORD THE IMPACTS OF NOT
HAVING A RELIABLE MAILING
ADDRESS ARE DETRIMENTAL TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN NEED,
UH, AND ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
WITHOUT SET STANDARDS THAT
EXPAND ACCESS TO RECEIVING MAIL.
THIS SHORTCOMING CAN POTENTIALLY
IMPACT AN ESTIMATED THOUSANDS OF
UNHOUSED. WHO WOULD LOSE
BENEFITS OR HAVE ACCESS
DISRUPTED THIS BILL PROVIDES
ASSURANCE FOR UNHOUSED
CALIFORNIANS TO RECEIVE THEIR
GOVERNMENT RELATED MAIL BY
REQUIRING THE COUNTIES DEVELOP
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE SUCH
RESIDENTS HAVE A DESIGNATED
PLACE TO RECEIVE AND PICK UP
CORRESPONDENCE. THIS WILL
PROVIDE UNHOUSED CALIFORNIANS
WITH AN OPTION TO RELIABLE AND
CONSISTENT ACCESS TO CRITICAL
SAFETY, NET SERVICES PROGRAMS
AND OTHER IMPORTANT GOVERNMENT
RELATED MAIL. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. I'M COMMITTED TO
NARROWING THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
IS ACCEPTABLE GOVERNMENT RELATED
MAIL AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
REGARDING THE CAPACITY OF COUNTY
STAFF TO IMPLEMENT THIS WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ, ONE OF OUR SPONSORS THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAND POVERTY,
UH, TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND, UH
RES, UH, ANSWERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. UM WHEN YOU'RE READY,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IN TWO MINUTES FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ WITH THE
MESA VERDE GROUP REPRESENTING
THE CO SPONSORS, THE WESTERN
CENTER AROUND POVERTY AND THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS. FIRST I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF, UH, FOR WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND US AS SPONSORS ONCE
AGAIN THIS YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO GET THIS
LEGISLATION RIGHT AS YOU MAY BE
AWARE, THE POST OFFICE IS NOT
THE SAME AS IT WAS IN THE PAST
FOR MULTIPLE REASONS, BUT
CERTAIN SERVICES THAT HAVE
HELPED THOSE WITHOUT A MAILING
ADDRESS SUCH AS A HOUSE
CALIFORNIANS. UM ARE NOT BEING
PROVIDED ARE NOT PRIORITIZED AT
THE POST OFFICE, UM, SUCH AS
WHAT THE SENATOR HAS SPOKEN
ABOUT, WHICH HAS ULTIMATELY BEEN
THE ONE WAY FOLKS HAVE CONNECTED
TO OUR STATE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. UH UNFORTUNATELY, UM,
UNDER SEVERAL ADMINISTRATIONS,
THE POST OFFICES IS CLOSING OR
CUTTING HOURS. UH, MAKING THIS
THIS REALITY A MORE
INACCESSIBLE. UH, LAST YEAR, THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAND POVERTY,
PUBLISHED A REPORT ON THIS TOPIC
THAT SHOWED NOT HAVING A MAILING
ADDRESS FURTHER DISENFRANCHISES
THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO ACCESS
PUBLIC BENEFITS. THE REPORT
FOUND THAT NOT HAVING A
CENTRALIZED MAILING ADDRESS
CREATED A LOT OF PROBLEMS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
ATTEMPTING ATTEMPTING TO COMPLY
WITH REQUESTS THAT ARE SENT
THROUGH THE MAIL, UM, FROM
SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'RE ENROLLED IN ARE BY THE
COUNTY ARE IN SOME CASES, EVEN
THE COURT SYSTEM WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY ENROLLED INTO
THESE PROGRAMS, IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ACTUALLY MAKE SURE
ACTUALLY CONNECTED TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO GET THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR THEIR EB Tð CARD. UH,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND IT'S
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE IT TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO THE MICROPHONE. STATE YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN. JARED, CALL WITH NOURISH
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WELL NOW
GIVE TIME TO THE OPPOSITION TO
COME FORWARD ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? WELCOME. YOU'LL HAVE
TWO MINUTES FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
IF YOU CAN JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION BEFORE YOU
START. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, UM,
EILEEN CUBANS WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL,
REGRETFULLY, UM, PROVIDING MAIL
SERVICES FOR UNHOUSED
INDIVIDUALS IS GOING TO PRESENT
UM SIGNIFICANT AND COSTLY
OPERATIONAL CHALLENGES, AND IT'S
NOT JUST STAFFING, ALTHOUGH THAT
IS ABSOLUTELY A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN. UM WE HAVE OTHER
CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS, INCLUDING
PHYSICAL CAPACITY, UM, SECURITY
PRIVACY. MANAGING THE MALE. UH
IT'S NÓ SMALL UNDERTAKING AND
WOULD REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
ADDITIONAL SPACE FOR THE MAIL
COLLECTION. THE SORTING, UH, THE
MAILBOXES THEMSELVES THE
ADEQUATE SECURITY, PARTICULARLY
FOR OUR LARGER URBAN COUNTIES.
UM THE PROPOSED PROGRAM ALSO
INCREASES LIABILITY FOR CLAIMS
OF LOST, MISPLACED OR DELAYED
MAIL. THIS WOULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL, UM, COST TO
COUNTIES. SOME COUNTIES, HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES DO OFFER
LIMITED MAIL SERVICES, BUT
THEY'RE CLIENTS OF PROGRAMS THAT
WE ALREADY OPERATE, UM, FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS, AND SO, UM, THIS
BILL GREATLY EXPANDS, UH, THAT
MANDATE AND GIVEN THE FISCAL
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT, UH, COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE THE FINANCIAL STAFFING OR
STRUCTURAL CAPACITY AT THIS TIME
TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL. YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR NOW OPEN
IT UP TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WELL NOW
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS. QUESTIONS SENATOR
WAHAB. THANK YOU. UM SO I HAVE
HISTORICALLY WORKED WITH THE
UNHOUSED POPULATION
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT, UM, A LOT OF
THE UNHOUSED INDIVIDUALS ALSO
WORK WITH NONPROFITS THAT
SOMETIMES YOU KNOW THEY USE, UM,
THEIR ADDRESS AND SO FORTH. UM,
ALSO, I JUST WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR TO THE LARGER PUBLIC
THAT THE COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SOCIAL
SERVICES OF THAT PARTICULAR
COUNTY. UH, WHETHER THAT'S
HOUSING, WHETHER THAT'S FOOD
BANKS, WHETHER THAT'S YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS IN
EACH COUNTY IS VERY DIFFERENT.
UM AND I'M I'M UNDER THE
IMPRESSION OBVIOUSLY, SENATOR DE
RAZZO CLEARLY STATED THAT SHE IS
NARROWING SCOPE. UM AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE THIS A VIABLE
OPTION. I THINK IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT EFFORTS
LIKE THIS. AND THE REASON I'M
GOING TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE. IN OUR
COUNTY, WHICH IS NOT NECESSARILY
A RURAL COUNTY. UM WHEN WE HAD
COVID TESTING AND COVID
INFORMATION AND SO FORTH. A LOT
OF IT WAS DONE ONLINE AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES AND SO FORTH COULD
NOT EVEN NECESSARILY APPLY TO
GET A COVID SHOT. BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO INTERNET
OR SO FORTH AND MUCH MORE. UM I
THINK THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO
MAKE THINGS ACCESSIBLE TO THE
LARGER PUBLIC, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN TALK ABOUT
IN REGARDS TO PROCESS FOR
EXAMPLE, UM, OUR LOCAL LIBRARIES
OR LOCAL CITIES, UM,
PARTNERSHIPS THAT THE COUNTY
ALREADY HAS WITH A LOT OF THESE
AGENCIES AND LOCATIONS THAT ARE
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY
RIGHT IN RURAL AREAS, AS WELL AS
MORE METRO SUBURBAN AREAS, SO UM
, I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THIS
EFFORT AND TRYING TO PRIORITIZE.
YOU KNOW, UNHOUSED. PEOPLE
DESERVE THE DIGNITY THAT ALL OF
US HAVE. AND SOME OF US TAKE FOR
GRANTED. SO I'LL RESPECTFULLY
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SENATOR CBO. KIND OF CURIOUS
SENATOR BECAUSE I BELIEVE I
SUPPORTED THE SIMILAR BILL OR
THIS BILL LAST YEAR, UM PRIOR TO
HAVING OPPOSITION FROM THE
COUNTIES, BUT HOW, UM HAVE YOU?
HAVE YOU ENVISIONED? HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO FACILITATE
THE COST OF IMPLEMENTING THIS
BILL. HOW HOW WE WOULD BE
FACILITATED. HAS THERE BEEN A
FINANCIAL ASK A BUDGET. ASK ON
THIS END TO HELP. FACILITATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT. YEAH,
THAT'S NOT I HAVEN'T TAKEN THAT
UP BECAUSE THIS IS THE POLICY.
UM POLICY COMMITTEE, SO IT'S NOT
BEEN SOMETHING I'VE ASKED FOR,
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT ANYTHING
HAS BEEN UM, PROMOTED HERE. BUT
I, I DO. I DO WANNA REMIND US
THAT, UM, WHEN THERE IS, UH SUCH
INSTABILITY AMONGST THE UNHOUSED
THAT THEY COULD LOSE THEIR
BENEFITS HAVE LOST THEIR
BENEFITS. HOW DO THEY GET BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE
BIG CHALLENGES FOR US RESOLVING
THE UNHOUSED THE ISSUE OF THE
UNHOUSED WE THEY CANNOT HAVE
INSTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED, AND SO YOU KNOW THEY IF
THEY LOSE IT, THEN IT'S AN EVEN
GREATER BURDEN. I THINK ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THEIR BENEFITS
IF THEY FALL IN OR THEY FALL OUT
, SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ALSO INCLUDE, UM
THE THAT STABILITY ALSO MEANS
THAT THERE'S LESS OF A BURDEN ON
THE ON THE, UH, PUBLIC SERVICES.
UM AGENCIES, SO I JUST WANNA ADD
THAT THAT IT'S NOT JUST A FLAT
OUT IT'S GONNA COST US MORE. BUT
THINK ABOUT HOW MUCH IS SAVED BY
HAVING STABILITY AMONGST THE
UNHOUSED BEING ABLE TO GET THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. THERE'S
HOUSING. THERE'S FOOD. UM
THERE'S A LOT OF SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED, AND SO I THINK THAT'S
ALSO NEEDS TO BE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. BUT THIS IS NOT. UM
THIS IS NOT THE, UM, THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND, UH, I WANNA
ADDRESS THE POLICY RAMIFICATIONS
AND I COMPLETELY RESPECT THAT. I
WAS JUST GONNA CURIOUS AS AS WE
LOOK INTO OUR BILLS, AND WE LOOK
INTO HOW DO WE FACILITATE? HOW
DO THEY COME INTO FRUITION? IT'S
ONE OF THE ASPECTS THAT I THAT I
THINK ABOUT IS LIKE, OK, HOW
WOULD WE BE ABLE TO FINANCE THE
FINANCIAL ESPECIALLY WHEN I
ABOUT EDUCATION AND FUTURE AND
EDUCATION. AND I THINK, OK, I
WOULD LOVE FOR THEM TO DO THIS,
BUT HOW WILL THEY BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT IT? UM IF WE'RE NOT
ALLOCATING ADDITIONAL FUNDING,
SO I'M JUST WORRIED ABOUT AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE IS MY CONCERN,
SO YEAH, I. I WOULD JUST SAY
ALSO THAT, UM, COUNTIES LIKE SAN
BERNARDINO, WHICH IS, IS MORE
MEDIUM SIZE IN LOS ANGELES,
WHICH IS URBAN AND MASSIVE. THEY
HAVE FIGURED THIS OUT. THEY HAVE
ALL THEIR FORMS. THEY YOU KNOW,
THEY PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
STABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MALE, SO I WOULD SEARCH MORE
WITH HOW THEY'RE DOING IT. AND
THEY ARE PROVIDING IT, I. I
DON'T KNOW IF MR SANCHEZ HAS
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD. UH, YES,
BRIEFLY. MRS SANCHEZ. IF YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS THE QUESTION,
YES, JUST BRIEFLY. A LOT OF
COUNTIES HAVE SOMETHING SIMILAR
SET UP AND I THINK, UM SAN
BERNARDINO HAPPENS TO BE A
REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE. UM
ESPECIALLY HOW LARGE IS SO I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, THE
COST WOULDN'T BE AS AS AS
SIGNIFICANT AS IT MIGHT BE
SOUNDING BECAUSE THERE IS SOME
TYPE OF SYSTEM IN PLACE AT AT
MOST COUNTIES. HUMAN SERVICE.
THE AGENCIES DO. HAVE OPTIONS,
AND MANY DO PROVIDE PHYSICAL
MAIL BOXES FOR CLIENTS OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE OPERATE. UM BUT
THIS BILL IS BEYOND THOSE
PROGRAMS. WE HAVE, UH, DIFFERENT
WAYS OF ENSURING THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE RUN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
DOCUMENTS AND OTHER UM,
IMPORTANT, UM, INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED RELATED TO THOSE
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. THOSE ARE
CLIENTS OF OUR PROGRAMS. THOSE
ARE KNOWN TO US THIS THIS BILL
IS MUCH BROADER THAN THAT. AND
THAT'S WHERE OUR OPERATIONAL
CONCERNS ARE. BASED THANK YOU.
SENATOR CIOBO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM YOU? NÓ. I'M
GOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO I
DO WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
, UM, THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING AMENABLE TO WORKING
WITH WITH OUR CONSULTANTS AND
WITH MY OFFICE AS WELL, I THINK
YOU'VE GOTTEN TO A REALLY GREAT
PLACE. UM I ALSO, UM THANK YOU
FOR NARROWING THE SCOPE. WHAT I
AM SEEING HERE IS THAT THIS IS
GOVERNMENT RELATED MAIL THAT HAS
TO DO WITH FOOD AND HOUSING,
LEGAL DOCUMENTS AND STATE AND
FEDERAL BENEFITS. AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE SOME
FEDERAL BENEFITS THAT ARE NOT
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTERED AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL. HOWEVER THESE
ARE VETERANS BENEFITS. THESE ARE
BENEFITS THAT ARE FOR BASIC
HOUSING AND LIVING EXPENSES. AND
SO, UM, I WOULD JUST IMPLORE OUR
OUR COUNTIES TO LOOK AT IT FROM
A WIDER LENS. AND ALTHOUGH WE
ARE, UM WE ARE A STATE AND WE
HAVE OUR STATE BENEFITS THAT
LEAD IN HOW WE TREAT OUR
NEIGHBORS, HOW WE TREAT OUR
COMMUNITY AND HOW WE TREAT OUR
UNHOUSED POPULATION, WHICH HAS
BEEN INCREASING YEAR AFTER YEAR.
SO AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO PUT
IN SOME SAFETY NETS TO ENSURE
THAT ACCESS TO FOOD HOUSING
HEALTHCARE LEGAL DOCUMENTS IS
PUT IN PLACE. I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS, AND THIS IS A BROAD
QUESTION. BUT PERHAPS YOU CAN
HELP STEER US WHAT WILL IT TAKE
TO GIVE COUNTIES THE CONFIDENCE
THAT THEY CAN IMPLEMENT THIS? I
RECUR. YOU'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF LOOKING AT WHAT
RESOURCES WE WOULD NEED TO MAKE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS FEASIBLE FOR
US. UM WE'VE NOT COMPLETED THAT
ANALYSIS YET, BUT CAN CERTAINLY
GET BACK TO YOU. IT IS, UM IT IS
A IT'S A NEW CHARGE FOR COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES. WE'VE
NOT DONE ANYTHING LIKE THIS ON A
BROAD SCALE BEFORE AND UM WOULD
WOULD NEED TO TAKE ALL OF THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION, NOT JUST
AROUND THE STAFFING, BUT
OBVIOUSLY AROUND THE PHYSICAL
SPACE NEEDED AS WELL AS OTHER
SECURITY AND TRAINING CONCERNS
AND SO FORTH. SO WE ARE IN THE
AS OF LOOKING INTO ALL OF THAT.
MAKING THAT ASSESSMENT. OK THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UM, SO OUR CHARGE
IN THIS GROUP IN THIS COMMITTEE
IS TO ASSESS POLICY AND HELP TO
STEER THAT POLICY FROM HERE. IT
DOES GO TO A BUDGET COMMITTEE
THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT THIS. SO
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE SOME OF
THE ANALYSIS TO OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND THROUGH THE
APPROPRIATIONS, SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR DURAZO? UM JUST THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE OUR OUR, UM IN OUR
CONTACT, UH, WITH THE COUNTIES.
UH, WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO MAKE
THIS SO, UH OVER BURDENSOME THAT
WE CAN'T DO WHAT'S NEEDED FOR
THE UNHOUSED. WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT THE COUNTIES DO
FOR OUR UNHOUSED CALIFORNIANS,
SO I MAKE THAT COMMITMENT TO
KEEP THAT CONVERSATION GOING AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. UM
ASSISTANT, WILL YOU, UH, MOVED
BY SENATOR WAHAB IF I'M NOT
INCORRECT? YES. ALL RIGHT. THIS
WHAT YOU CALL THE ROLL? FILE
ITEM TWO S¼ B 1107 DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. ALVARADO
GILL ALVARADO GILL, I ACHOA
BOGUE I A èC BOGUE EYE
BLAKESPEAR BLAKE SPEAR EYE
MENJIVAR MENJIVAR I, WAHAB
WAHAB. I THANK YOU. THAT'S 50,
AND THAT'S DO PASS IS AMENDED TO
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE NUMBER FOUR
SENATE BILL 1254. SENATOR
BECKER. ARE YOU READY? THANK
YOU. RIGHT AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT, UM
PLEASE INVITE THEM UP TO THE
MICROPHONES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ALVARADO, GIL AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT S¼ B 1254, A BILL THAT
ALLOWS AND ASSISTS INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN APPLYING FOR CAL FRESH
BENEFITS UP TO 90 DAYS BEFORE
THEIR RELEASE TO BETTER PREPARE
THEM FOR REENTRY. TO BE CLEAR
AGAIN. THIS BILL PROVIDES
INDIVIDUALS WITH A COW PRESSURE
UPON THEIR EXIT FROM A FACILITY.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ACCESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM SNAP
CALLED CAL IN CALIFORNIA,
SOMETIMES KNOWN AS FOOD STAMPS,
IS THE LARGEST FEDERAL FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN THE NATION
AGAIN JUST TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THESE ARE FEDERAL DOLLARS. WE'RE
DRAWING DOWN UNDER FEDERAL LAW,
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BECOME
INELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE COW FRESH
BENEFITS AFTER 90 DAYS OF
CONFINEMENT. HOWEVER THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ALLOWS FOR WAIVERS TO DEVIATE
FROM THAT CURRENT PROVISION, AND
IN FACT, 12 STATES ALREADY DO SO
. SO THEY'VE GOTTEN THE WAIVER
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR AS PART
OF THIS BILL. ALSO, ORANGE
COUNTY HAS A PILOT PROGRAM
BECAUSE COUNTIES CAN ALSO APPLY
FOR THE WAIVER ARE COUNTIES.
ORANGE COUNTY HAS A PILOT
PROGRAM OF CAL FRESH PRE
ENROLLMENT FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS APPLYING FOR THE
WAIVER IN 2021. THEY DO IT FOR
EVERYONE LEAVING AND THEY START
THE PROCESS. 30 DAYS BEFORE, UH,
SOMEONE EXITS AND IN FACT, WE'VE
TALKED TO THE SHERIFFS THERE
ABOUT THAT PROGRAM. FOOD
INSECURITY IS ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING HURDLES THAT
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FACE UPON RE ENTRY
AT NINE IN 2019, ROUGHLY ONE IN
FIVE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE SUFFERED FROM FOOD
INSECURITY. WELL CALIFORNIA HAS
TAKEN STEPS TO CREATE A RE ENTRY
PROCESS FOR MEDICAL BENEFITS. AS
YOU KNOW, THERE IS A GAP IN
CURRENT LAW TO CREATE AN
EQUIVALENT ENROLLMENT PROCESS
FOR CAL, FRESH AND A STATEWIDE
REENTRY PROCESS. S¼ P 1254
BUILDS UPON EXISTING WORK IN
CONNECTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
STATE SERVICES IN AN EFFECTIVE
MANNER, DECREASING BARRIERS,
REENTRY AND HELPING ADDRESS
ISSUES OF FOOD INSECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
BILL DOES IT REQUIRES èC Dð S¼
S¼ TO SUBMIT THE APPLICABLE
WAIVERS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ALLOW PRE
ENROLLMENT AS 12 OTHER STATES
HAVE HAVE DO AS I MENTIONED IT
ALSO CREATES, SECONDLY, A
WORKFORCE WITHIN èC Dð S¼ TO
DEVELOP AND SHARE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR STATEWIDE RE
ENTRY PROCESS, INCORPORATING ALL
THE POTENTIAL NECESSARY
RESOURCES FOR COUNCILS REENTRY
INTO THE COMMUNITY. FINALLY THE
BILL REQUIRES èC, Dð, S¼, èC
Dð, S¼ S¼ AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO CREATE
AND TEST A MEDICAL AND CAL FRESH
COMBINED APPLICATION FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS SOON,
UM, LEAVING INCARCERATION BY OR
ON JANUARY 1ST 2026 REMOVING
THESE BARRIERS WILL AGAIN
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AS WE WILL
HEAR ABOUT AND ALSO MAXIMIZE THE
UTILIZATION OF THIS FEDERALLY
FUNDED PROGRAM, WHICH, AS WE ALL
KNOW, IS UNDERUTILIZED ALREADY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. UM WE DO
HAVE ONE PROPOSED CLERICAL
AMENDMENT TO FURTHER CLARIFY
THAT THE WORK GROUP WILL SUBMIT
THE REPORT IN AUGUST OF 2026.
WE'VE CONSISTENTLY ENGAGED THE
OPPOSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. UM TO, UH,
HOPEFULLY HELP US WATCH THEIR
OPPOSITION WITH ME. CAMERON
JONES FROM NURSE CALIFORNIA AND
ALYSSA MOORE FROM LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE'LL HEAR
FROM OUR TWO WITNESSES FOR A TWO
MINUTES EACH. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. COM
COMMITTEE. I'M CAMERON MIMMS
JONES. I'M A SENIOR ADVOCATE
WITH NOURISH CALIFORNIA FOR OVER
30 YEARS, OUR MISSION HAS BEEN
TO ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
FOOD, HEALTH AND WELL-BEING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS, WHICH IS WHY
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF 1254 THE FOOD FOR
REENTRY AND ENSURING STABLE
HOMES ACT. SB 1254 STEMS FROM A
RESTORATIVE FRAMEWORK AND
UPSTREAM POLICY TO DIMINISH THE
ENDURING IMPACTS OF
INCARCERATION. ENABLING
INDIVIDUALS TO APPLY FOR COW
FRESH BENEFITS UP TO 90 DAYS
BEFORE RELEASE AND ESTABLISHING
A WORK GROUP TO OPTIMIZE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS NOT ONLY
ADDRESSES IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND
FOSTERS LONG-TERM WELL-BEING.
èC FRESH. OUR STATE'S BRANDED
NAME FOR SNAP HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE, HELPING MILLIONS TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. IT'S OUR
NATION'S MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI
POVERTY INITIATIVE, AND WE KNOW
THAT COMMUNITIES THRIVE WHEN
ACCESS TO NUTRITIOUS AND
CULTURALLY RELEVANT FOOD IS
PRIORITIZED AND ENSURED.
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY HINGES ON
TIMELY ACCESS TO BASICS LIKE
FOOD, TRANSPORTATION, HEALTH
CARE AND HOUSING, WHILE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS STAND READY
TO CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK.
EARLY ACCESS TO èC FRESH IS
PIVOTAL FOR INDIVIDUALS,
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION FROM
INCARCERATION TO COMMUNITY. AT
SPEECH. 1254 ISN'T JUST ABOUT
IDENTIFYING PROBLEMS BUT
CRAFTING COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS
BY ESTABLISHING A GROUP GROUP TO
BOLSTER A STATEWIDE REENTRY
PROCESS. THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
MORE CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE THE
SUPPORT NEEDED TO THRIVE WHILE
MAXIMIZING CURRENT EFFORTS TO
INTEGRATE THE STATE'S HUMAN
SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE. I ALSO
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT ABOUT
FOISTING OBLIGATIONS, IT'S ABOUT
GRANTING ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITIES
FOR VITAL RESOURCES. SB 1254
ASKED FOR A WAIVER TO EMPOWER
OUR COUNTIES TO DO THE NEED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR CITIZENS,
AND WE WELCOME COLLABORATION
WITH ALL INTERESTED PARTIES TO
REBUILD STRONGER COMMUNITIES
ALONGSIDE ONE ANOTHER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF 1254. THANK YOU. HØI
MY NAME IS ALYSSA MOORE WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. HØI EVERYONE, UM
IN IN RECOGNITION OF CESAR
CHÁVEZ AND HIS LEGACY OF
ORGANIZING COMMUNITY AMONGST
MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN HIS WORK AND THE
LEGISLATION UNDER YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY. WHILE THIS
BILL IS ON THE FACE IS SOCIAL
SERVICES AND TODAY BEFORE HUMAN
RESOURCES FOR ME, IT'S A COMMON
SENSE. PUBLIC SAFETY MEASURE
HELPS ELIMINATE FOOD INSECURITY
FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
PREPARING FOR RELEASE THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY MAKE CALIFORNIA A
SAFER PLACE FOR HALL. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF
COMING HOME FROM INCARCERATION,
INCREASED ACCESS TO CALF, FRESH
AND MEDICAL IMMEDIATELY UPON
RELEASE. THE PRE-EXISTING WAIVER
CURRENTLY IN PLACE IS NOT
WORKING AS IT SHOULD. AND I
BELIEVE THIS PROCESS WILL
STREAMLINE THAT. UH PLEASE
INDULGE ME IF THE COMMITTEE IS
UNAWARE, BUT UPON OUR RELEASE
FROM PRISON OR JAIL, IT'S
ROUTINE TO GO WITHOUT STABLE
ACCESS TO FOOD OR MEDICAL CARE
FOR UP TO 721 DAYS AS WE
NAVIGATE OUR HOMECOMING AND
OFTEN MUCH LONGER THIS IS THE
CURRENT STATE IN TRUE PICTURE OF
ACCESS TO EMERGENCY CALF, FRESH
AND MEDICAL BENEFITS AND VARIOUS
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES FOR ME, 7
TO 21 DAYS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
FOOD AND MEDICAL CARE. SHAMEFUL
REALITY THAT CAUSES MANY PEOPLE
TO TURN IN DESPERATION TO OLD
BEHAVIORS AS A MEANS OF
SURVIVAL. TO CONNECT THIS TO OUR
POPULATION DIRECTLY. AND
SPECIFICALLY, I'D LIKE TO SHARE
A STORY OF A FRIEND OF MINE WHO,
WHILE INCARCERATED, STRUGGLED
FIERCELY WITH AN OPIOID
ADDICTION SUBS. CURRENTLY SHE
WAS PLACED ON MAT THERAPY WHILE
SHE DID GET OFF THE OPIATES, SHE
WAS NOW CHEMICALLY DEPENDENT ON
THE MAT TREATMENT. SHE WENT OUT
TO COURT FOR A REVIEW OF HER
CASE AND WAS RELEASED FROM THE
COUNTY JAIL. ESSENTIALLY AS A
FREE PERSON. HER JOY WAS SHORT
LIVED, SHE WOULD SPEND WHAT WAS
TO BE A HORRIFIC 70. TWO HOURS
STRUGGLING TO GET VITAL
MEDICATION SHE NEEDED
DESPERATELY AND MAINTAIN HER
SOBRIETY AT THE SAME TIME. WOW
INHUMANE IS THAT YOU MAY ASK IF
YOU HAVE NEVER SEEN SOMEONE
SUFFER THROUGH. WITHDRAW YOU
WOULD NOT KNOW HOW TERRIFYING IT
IS TO EXPERIENCE OR WATCH WITH
NÓ WAY TO HELP. MY FRIEND WAS
SHAKING AND SWEATING AND WEAK,
AND HER BREATHING AT TIMES WAS
VERY LABORED. SHE WASN'T HELL.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE STATE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL ENTITIES TO
COLLABORATE TO MAKE THIS
LEGISLATION A REALITY FOR
CALIFORNIA, BRINGING, UM ALL
THOSE A FOUR MENTIONED ENTITIES
UP TO DATE WITH TODAY'S
REHABILITATION STANDARD IN
PUBLIC RECOGNITION THAT A SAFE
RE ENTRY IS A HUGE PART OF TRULY
REHABILITATION WITHOUT THIS MUCH
NEEDED LEGISLATION. CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS OF REHABILITATION FALL
SHORT OF THE MARK. I ASK YOU,
DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO INVEST
WHAT IS ASSUMED TO BE THOUSANDS
ANNUALLY IN REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS INTO ONE INDIVIDUAL AND
THEN ON PRONE UPON PAROLE, GIVE
THEM NÓ TRUE OPPORTUNITY NOT TO
RE OFFEND FOR A BASIC NEED OF
FOOD OR MEDICAL CARE. I ASK YOU
OK, UM WHAT ONE OF AMONG US
COULD GO 7 TO 21 DAYS WITHOUT
VITAL MEDICAL CARE, MEDICATION
OR FOOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, UM, ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL? COME TO
THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU.
PLEASE. STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
ONLY PLEASE. VÀ WITH JUSTICE AND
AGING AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ,
REPRESENTING THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA OFFER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, HENRY ORTIZ WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS FOR
CHILDREN AND ALL OF US IN
SACRAMENTO, AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CHRISTINA ROBINSON
WITH COMMUNITY HEALER. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. RIGHT, RIGHT
. WE'LL NOW MOVE FORWARD TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. DO WE
HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? OK? THANK YOU. BE
HEARING FROM BOTH OF YOU. I DID
GO OVER A LITTLE BIT WITH TWO
MINUTES, SO I'LL ALLOW YOU THAT
SAME LITTLE CUSHION OF TIME. UM,
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION AND START WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COREY CILLO,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO S¼ B 1254. WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF EASING
REENTRY OF FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PERSONS INTO SOCIETY. BUT THIS
BILL CREATES EXPENSIVE
CHALLENGES WITHOUT FUNDING OR
THE GUARANTEE THAT THE PROGRAM
WILL EVEN BE PERMITTED. IN ORDER
FOR THIS UNFUNDED MANDATE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED, STATE OFFICIALS
WOULD HAVE TO SEEK AND OBTAIN A
FEDERAL WAIVER AND THERE IS NÓ
ASSURANCE THAT SUCH WOULD OCCUR
FURTHER. CALIFORNIA STATE AND
LOCAL CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES,
AS YOU KNOW, ARE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A YEARS LONG, YEARS LONG
PROCESS TO IMPLEMENT THE SECOND
PART OF THE CALA JUSTICE
INVOLVED INITIATIVE, WHICH
REQUIRES THE PROVISION OF IN
REACH SERVICES TO COUNTY JAIL
INMATES WITHIN 90 DAYS OF
RELEASE, THIS COMPLEX AND NOVEL
PROGRAM WILL NOT BE ROLLED OUT
IN THE COUNTIES PRIOR TO
OCTOBER. 1ST 2024 AT THE
EARLIEST, AND NOT ALL COUNTIES
WILL BE READY OR WILLING TO
PROCEED AT THAT TIME. WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT LAYERING ON
ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT WILL
REQUIRE RESOURCES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNACCOUNTED FOR BOTH
IN FUNDING AND STAFF CAPACITY
WILL HAMSTRING LOCAL
CORRECTIONAL EFFORTS. WE ALSO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERN WITH
THE WORK GROUP. CREATED BY THE
BILL. IT'S MEANT TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON A PROGRAM. UM
THAT IS, UH, AS I STATED IN THE
LETTER FOISTED UPON COUNTY JAILS
THIS WORK GROUP. IF WE'RE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT COUNTY INPUT AND
COUNTY THOUGHTS ON THIS PROCESS,
UH, THE PROPONENTS FAILED TO PUT
EVEN A SINGLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE ON THIS WORK
GROUP, SO, ADDING A COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE DOESN'T
AMELIORATE OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL. UM, BUT IT JUST I, I THINK
TELLS AN INTERESTING STORY
ABOUT, UM ABOUT THE BILL AND
ABOUT THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE,
SO WE CERTAINLY OBJECT TO THE
LACK OF A JAIL OFFICIAL BEING
INCLUDED OR FAILED TO BE
INCLUDED, UM, ESPECIALLY WHILE
THE BILL REQUIRES
REPRESENTATIVES FROM COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS, UM AND
OTHERS WHO DO NOT REPRESENT
COUNTIES. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
AND, UH WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NÓ VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I THINK YOU CAN FANCY WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD SAY THIS IS
ONE WHERE THE ON THE POLICY
WHERE ABSOLUTELY IN SUPPORT, UM
TO MR SALA'S POINT, THOUGH, WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING THE SECOND PART
OF THE JUSTICE INVOLVED
INITIATIVE OF CAL. AIM UM, WE'RE
ROLLING THAT OUT. THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN QUITE AN EXTENSIVE
, UM, VERY INVOLVED. PROCESS ONE
THAT WILL NOT BE COMPLETED UNTIL
LATER THIS YEAR AT THE EARLIEST.
I THINK WE CAN LEARN A LOT OF
LESSONS. HOW THAT GOES AND BUILD
UPON THE STRUCTURES AND CONTEXTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING UNDER THAT
INITIATIVE, BUT WE HAVEN'T GOT
THOSE YET. AND SO, UM, IF
NOTHING ELSE WE ARE. WE ARE KNEE
DEEP IN THAT IMPLEMENTATION
WOULD WANT TO GET THROUGH THAT,
UM, ALSO, TO THE POINT THAT WE
DO NEED A FEDERAL WAIVER TO DO
THIS, SO THE TIMELINE BY WHICH
THIS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE BILL COULD
POTENTIALLY BE BEFORE WE WOULD
HAVE SUCH A WAIVER, SO WE WOULD
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE DO GET
THE WAIVER AND KIND OF PROCEED
FROM THERE, AND I THINK THERE
ARE THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS TO
STRUCTURE THAT WAIVER AND WE
WOULD WANT TO BE INVOLVED IN IN
THINKING THROUGH HOW WE MIGHT DO
THAT, IN A WAY THAT MIGHT MAKE
IT MOST EFFECTIVE TO IMPLEMENT
AND AGAIN BUILDING UPON THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW, UM,
WITH THE, UH, MEDICAL PROGRAM IN
CAL LANE, UM, THE OTHER, UM, UH,
PIECES ON THE WORK GROUP AND,
UH, I, I DO. UH, ALSO, UH UH, I
WILL SAY WE DON'T OBJECT TO
ACTUALLY BEING INVOLVED IN OTHER
WORK GROUP. WE DO THINK,
ACTUALLY, IF WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT HOW WE BROUGHT IN CAL
FRESH ACCESS TO INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALL INDIVIDUALS
IN CALIFORNIA, THE COUNTY HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY SHOULD HAVE A
PLACE AT THAT TABLE AND SO WE
WOULD ASK TO BE INVOLVED IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. BUT AT THIS
POINT, THE TIMING OF THE BILLS,
REQUIREMENTS AND THE WAIVER AND
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING ON
KI¾M, UM IT'S ALL HAPPENING AT
ONCE, ACCORDING TO THE TIMELINES
OF THIS BILL, AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, UM, WE HAVE WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT IT. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR SHARING YOUR CONCERNS.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
WITH THEIR OPPOSITION RIGHT
RIGHT SEEN, THEN WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO COMMITTEE
SENATOR MENJIVAR AND SENATOR W.
I WAS HOPING AS A CO-AUTHOR. I
WOULD BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS BILL.
UH NÓ. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR. I YOU KNOW, CO AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE, I KNOW THE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT ESPECIALLY A
LOT OF OUR YOUTH. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT JUVENILE AS CAME OUT OF
THE, UH, JUVENILE HALLS TO GET
CONNECTED TO CRE. EVEN WITH
COLLEGE STUDENTS HAS BEEN A
THING THAT WE NEED TO CLOSE THE
GAP ON ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL FRESH. I KNOW
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT. UM
UH, YOU KNOW, THE èC A
INITIATIVE JUSTICE INITIATIVE,
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS WAIVER WAS
APPROVED LAST YEAR, AND WE'RE
STILL IN THE PROCESS. IT TAKES A
LITTLE WHILE AND I KNOW
COMMITTED TO ENSURING WE COME UP
TO A DATE THAT IS GONNA BE
FEASIBLE AND ALSO, AND ALSO,
IT'S GONNA WORK, RIGHT? WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE BOTH HAVE THE
MEDI WAIVER AND THE èC FRESH
WAIVER MORE THAN HAPPY TO MOVE
THIS BOW AND I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TALKING
TO THE COUNTIES AND FINDING THAT
SWEET SPOT OF A DATE. THANK YOU.
I AM INDEED. THANK YOU. OR WHAT?
THANK YOU, UM, SPECIFICALLY.
WEAR MULTIPLE HATS. OBVIOUSLY
I'M CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY AS
WELL. AND SINCE WE'RE FOCUSED ON
THE HUMAN SERVICES PIECE, I DO
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT REHABILITATION AND
PROVIDING SERVICES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT, UM I DON'T FEEL THAT
WE DO ENOUGH FOR REENTRY. ACROSS
THE BOARD. THAT IS MY PERSONAL
FEELINGS ABOUT IT, RIGHT? UM I
THINK THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HEARD WHICH I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
IMPLEMENTATIONS, SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT. WORKING GROUP TAKES
TIME. A LOT OF PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE. UM, I DO AGREE THAT, UM
SOMEBODY FROM LIKE LOCAL
COUNTIES AND I. I BELIEVE IF I'M
READING THIS CORRECTLY, YOU HAVE
, UH, EVEN NUMBERED OF
INDIVIDUALS ON THIS WORKING
GROUP. UM I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
YOU KNOW, POTENTIALLY, YOU KNOW,
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON JUST
REPRESENTING COUNTIES
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT, YOU
KNOW, PROVIDE THE SOCIAL
SERVICES, RIGHT? UM I ALSO WANT
TO SAY THAT, YOU KNOW, OFTEN
TIMES IN CALIFORNIA, WE HEAR A
LOT OF ELECTED SPEAK ABOUT WHERE
THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. WE ARE THE MAIN FOOD
PRODUCERS OF THE WORLD. WE ARE
XY AND Z. OF THE WORLD. AND YET,
YOU KNOW THIS IS BASIC DIGNITY
OF HEALTHY FOODS FOR INDIVIDUALS
AT THEIR, YOU KNOW, MOST
VULNERABLE TIME. UH REENTRY IS
VERY TRAUMATIZING FOR A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS. WE HEAR THIS FROM
EVEN OUR UNHOUSED POPULATION
THAT OFTEN TIMES IF YOU DO
PROVIDE HOUSING, OR SOME TYPE OF
ADDITIONAL SERVICE THAT THEY
HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT HAD THEY
HAVE A LOT OF TRAUMA GETTING
USED TO THAT AND IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ON THE ISSUES OF
FINDING EMPLOYMENT, FINDING
HOUSING, RECONNECTING WITH
FAMILY MEMBERS, UH, WRITING A
LOT OF WRONGS THAT SOME
INDIVIDUALS HAVE A PURPOSE OF
DOING ONCE THEY ARE RELEASED.
HEALTHY FOOD SHOULD NOT BE TOP
OF THAT LIST. THIS IS BASIC
DIGNITY THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
FOR ALL PEOPLE, UH, REGARDLESS
OF STATUS, REGARDLESS OF
SOCIO-ECONOMIC BACKGROUND,
REGARDLESS OF A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS, SO, UM, I FULLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I SUPPORT THE EFFORT.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION STILL TO BE HAD. I
KNOW THAT I'M GOING TO BE
VIEWING IT FROM A DIFFERENT
LOUDNESS WHEN IT COMES TO MY
COMMITTEE, BUT FROM A HUMAN
SERVICES PERSPECTIVE, I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE WORK. I HOPE
THAT YOU CAN WORK WITH SOME OF
THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS AS THIS
MOVES ALONG AND WE'LL SEE IT
OBVIOUSLY AGAIN. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE. I APPRECIATE YOU
GUYS, UH, MENTIONING SOME OF
YOUR CONCERNS AS WELL. SO THANK
YOU. RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
SENATOR Ó CIOBO? YES. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING, UM, YOUR STORY
IS VERY COMPELLING. UM, I
ACTUALLY SAT IN PUBLIC SAFETY
FOR QUITE A WHILE AND LEARNED OF
THE MANY CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR FORMAL INCARCERATED.
WORKING TOWARDS REENTERING THE
THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE ON
THAT END, SO I'M I'M VERY
COMPELLED BY THE NEED AND THE
MERIT OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO,
UH, PROPOSE, BUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS. DO WE KNOW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF THE WAIVER UM DOES NOT
GO THROUGH. WHAT? WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE INTENT OF THIS BILL?
OUR ANTICIPATION IS THAT THE
WAIVER WILL GO THROUGH SINCE 12.
OTHER STATES HAVE GOTTEN IT. UM
AND ORANGE COUNTY HAS, UM, IF WE
DON'T GET 
WHATEVER REASON, UM THEN THEN WE
DON'T HAVE THE WAIVER. THEN THEN
, UM, YOU KNOW, WE CAN'T GO
FORWARD AT THAT POINT, SO IT
DOES REQUIRE US TO GET THE
WAIVER. OK? AND THEN, UM IS
THERE A REASON WHY THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE COUNTY
AND FROM THE SHERIFFS OR FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE IN THE PANEL? I
THINK WE'RE JUST TRYING TO GET A
GOOD GROUP OF FOLKS. WE'RE
CERTAINLY OPEN TO FURTHER
CONVERSATION. CERTAINLY WITH THE
COUNTY. I THINK THE SHERIFFS
WEREN'T ABLE TO HAVE A MEETING.
SO I DON'T THINK WE WERE QUITE
DISCUSSED THAT, BUT, UM, OPEN TO
DISCUSSING THAT AS WELL. BUT I
THINK, UH, I HEAR THE FEEDBACK
FROM THE UM, COMMITTEE ABOUT
HAVING SOMEONE FROM THE COUNTIES
. UM AND UM AND I WOULD ADD THE
SHERIFFS TO JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED BY THE WORK THAT'S
GOING TO BE REQUIRED. UM, THE
OTHER THING. UM, SO HOW WOULD
YOU TO THE FACT THAT RIGHT NOW,
UM AND THIS IS WHERE I'M SORRY.
SORRY EXCUSE ME. HOLD ON ALL
COMMUNICATIONS TO THE CHAIR,
PLEASE. YES I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT SENATOR CIOBO CAN HAVE A
CHANCE TO FINISH YOUR QUESTION.
AND THEN WE'LL GET YOUR ANSWERS.
SO ON THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED WITH THE CALIFORNIA THE
STATE CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
BEING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE YEAR
LONG PROCESS TO IMPLEMENT THE
SECOND PART OF THE KING JUSTICE
INVOLVED INITIATIVE, UM IT SAYS
HERE IT WILL REQUIRE UH, IN
REACH SERVICES TO COUNTY JAIL
INMATES WITHIN 90 DAYS OF
RELEASE, SO THIS PROGRAM IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY WAS IS
INTENDED TO CONNECT, UH, INMATES
WITH SERVICES PRIOR TO BEING
RELEASED, SO WOULD HAVE ASSUMED
THAT WE WOULD HAVE IMPLEMENTED
AND GOTTEN THIS PROGRAM THROUGH
AND THEN ADDED THE SERVICES SUCH
AS CALF FRESH INTO IT. I DON'T
KNOW. I DON'T REMEMBER.
ORIGINALLY WHY THAT WASN'T
INCLUDED AS ONE OF THE SERVICES
THAT WERE, UM PART OF THE CALM
PROCESS. BUT UM, WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY ABOUT WAITING TO HAVE THIS
IMPLEMENTED? AND I KNOW FROM THE
URGENCY PART OF IT. YOU DID SAY,
LET'S NOT WAIT BECAUSE WE, YOU
KNOW WHO SHOULD NOT BE WEIGHT,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHY FOOD WAS
NOT INCLUDED. IN THIS PARTICULAR
UM, UM, INITIATIVE, BUT ALLOWING
THE, UM THE CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM FIRST TO SEE WHAT IS
WORKING AND NOT WORKING. UM HOW
WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
EXCEPT FOR THE URGENCY, PART OF
THE FOOD PART? YOU KNOW, IF I
CAN ANSWER THEN MAYBE HAVE OUR
WITNESSES SHARE. WOULD THAT BE
OK? UM JUST AAA QUICK REACTION.
THE, UM YOU KNOW, I? I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT ANSWER TO THAT.
THE QUESTION. I MEAN, I THINK
THE CALUM ME ARE STATE AND THIS
IS A WE'RE APPLYING FOR THE
FEDERAL WAIVER. SO MAYBE THAT'S
WHY IT WAS, YOU KNOW, REGARDED
SEPARATELY. UM YOU KNOW, THE
MAIN POINT IS WE WANT, YOU KNOW
TO GET THIS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
TO, UM UH, FOR PEOPLE WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY LEAVE, UM, BUT IN
TERMS OF THE 2026 DEADLINE IS
REALLY ABOUT THAT KIND OF
INTEGRATED PROCESS. AND YOU KNOW
IF PEOPLE FEEL THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME. I THINK WE'D BE
OPEN TO, UM, YOU KNOW, POSSIBLY
EXTENDING THAT, UM, MAYBE SOME
PERIOD OF TIME AFTER THE WAIVER
IS GRANTED OR SOMETHING FOR THAT
, BUT THAT WAS REALLY FOR THE
INTEGRATED PROCESS. AND I THINK
WE'D BE OPEN TO EX EXTENDING
THAT IF THERE'S A BELIEF AT THAT
TIMELINE IS TOO DIFFICULT. BUT
LET ME TURN OVER TO MY WITNESSES
ON BOTH QUESTIONS IF YOU COULD,
UM, YES. SO TO SPEAK TO BOTH
THINGS THAT YOU ADDRESSED THE
WORK GROUP, UM IN AS A BUILDING
THE WORK GROUP. FRANKLY AS
ADVOCATES WE ARE NOT AWARE OF,
YOU KNOW, SORT OF WHO WE WHO WE
ASK SO WE BY ASKING èC Dð èC R
. WE ACTUALLY THOUGHT WE WERE
INVITING THE SHERIFF, SO THAT'S
SO ONCE AGAIN ALWAYS OPEN TO ALL
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PART OF
THE TRANSITION FOR INDIVIDUALS
WOULD LOVE FOR THEM TO HAVE BEEN
AT THE TABLE. SO HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM BE A PART OF THIS WORK
GROUP. BUT UM, ALSO TO SPEAK TO
WHAT YOUR OTHER QUESTION IS. THE
WAIVER IS REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE COW FRESH WHILE PEOPLE
ARE CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. UM
IT THAT'S LITERALLY ALL IT DOES
IT. WE HAVE TO ASK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN ORDER TO EASE THE
RESTRICTION THAT REQUIRES THEM
TO BE AN INDIVIDUAL TO BE
INELIGIBLE TO INCARCERATION. AND
IF WE DON'T HAVE A WAIVER, WE
CAN'T TEST ANYTHING. AND SO
THAT'S THE WAIVER. AS A WAIVER
THAT WAS SOUGHT IN IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND OSTENSIBLY, WE'RE
ASKING TO MODIFY THAT WAIVER.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
INDICATION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THOSE WHO ARE IN PART
OF PROCESSING THAT OR NOT, UM,
ANYTHING BUT EXCITED,
EXHILARATED WITH THE IDEA THAT
CALIFORNIA IS FINALLY GOING TO
FULLY UTILIZE ITS ITS BENEFIT OF
THE FEDERAL BENEFIT, AND IT
WOULD HAVE TO DO THAT BY SEEKING
THE FEDERAL WAIVER. AND SO THAT
IS THE REASON WHY I WAS NOT A
PART OF THE COW LANE PROCESS,
AND I ASSUME THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS WHY THEY DIDN'T ASK TO
PUT COW FRESH AS A PART OF THAT
PROCESS. IF WE HAD BEEN AT THE
TABLE, WE WOULD HAVE TOLD THEM
THEY SHOULD HAVE HAD TO PUT
COWFISH PART OF THE PROCESS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE ASSESSING
FOR A MEDICAL BENEFIT. THERE'S
ONLY TWO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS SO
WE WOULD LOVE FOR I WOULD HAVE
LOVED THAT. BUT RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE TO GET THE WAIVER IN ORDER
TO MAXIMIZE CAL FRESH AS AN
OPTION FOR FOLKS ENTERING
RETURNING BACK TO COMMUNITY THAT
AND SO I HOPE THAT ANSWERS THIS
QUESTION. SO WANT TO GIVE A
CHANCE. POSITION TO ADDRESS IT
OR HAVE QUESTIONS. I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY WITH RESPECT TO CAL,
AIM THOSE THAT WAS, UH, THOSE
REQUIRED A COUPLE OF WAIVERS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, UM,
ON THE MEDICAID SIDE, SO TOTALLY
DIFFERENT GOVERNMENTAL AGENCY,
UH, TOTALLY DIFFERENT WAIVER.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT RULES. I MEAN,
UM ALL IN SUPPORT OF PUSHING THE
FEDS AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
SIMPLIFY AND ALIGN SOME OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND ELIGIBILITY
AND TIMING. BENEFITS WHERE THE
FEDS FOR FEDERAL BENEFITS, SO,
UM, THAT'S PARTLY WHY WE'D LIKE
TO ALSO BE INVOLVED IN SOME OF
THE WAIVER CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE KIND OF MAXIMIZING,
UH, THE FLEXIBILITIES THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEEK, OR AT LEAST TRY
TO ANYWAY, UM, BUT THAT'S THAT'S
WHY A DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
FEDERAL AGENCIES. DIFFERENT
FEDERAL WAIVERS REQUIRED. UM AND
CAL AIM JUST DEALT WITH THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICAID SERVICES ON
THE MEDICAID SIDE. SO, MADAM
CHAIR, JUST FINAL THOUGHT SO.
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
WAS THE CASE. AM JUST CURIOUS AS
TO WHY THEY WERE LOOKING INTO
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM OR
THEY WERE LOOKING AT HEALTH
CARE. AND WHAT IS IT THE OTHER
ONE? THERE'S ANOTHER ONE. RIGHT?
WHEN THEY WERE LOOKING AT THAT,
UM THEY DIDN'T LOOK TO SEE WHICH
OTHER AREAS COMPONENTS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO GET WAIVERS AND
IMPLEMENT AS PEOPLE ARE LEAVING,
UM, THE PRISON SYSTEM. UM I'M
GOING TO, UM I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT AND I THINK IT'S VERY
WELL INTENDED. I'M GONNA WAIT TO
SEE WHAT THE FINAL LANGUAGE IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE, AS FAR AS
ACCOMMODATING THE ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE. HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT AS WELL
AS, UM THERE WAS THE OTHER ONE.
THE REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
WAIVER PART OF IT. I'M GOING TO
SEE WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE AT THE
AT THE END. UM, BEFORE I SUPPORT
THE BILL, SO I'M GONNA I'M NOT
GONNA VOTE NÓ ON IT TODAY, BUT I
WILL STAY OFF OF IT TO SEE HOW
YOU WERE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
CONCERNS OF THE COUNTIES AND THE
UM AND THE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION,
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY WELL
INTENDED. I THINK IT'S NEEDED,
UM AND WE DO I. I THINK IT YOU
KNOW WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO AVOID
PEOPLE GOING BACK TO THE OLD
HABITS AND TO NOT HABITS. I
WOULDN'T SAY HABITS BUT YOUR
WAYS OF WHAT GOT HIM
INCARCERATED. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. UM AND THIS IS COMING
FROM SOMEONE WHO, UM I'M NOT
VERY HAPPY RIGHT NOW, WITH THE
AMOUNT OF CRIME THAT'S HAPPENING
IN OUR STATE. UM, YOU KNOW SO
UM, I'M GONNA LAY OFF AT THIS
TIME, BUT THANK YOU. ME. NEITHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN THE
COMMITTEE. OK, ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR BECKER. SO YOU AND I
HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER TO
POLISH UP THIS BILL, AND, UM, I.
I APPRECIATE YOUR INTENT ON THIS
BILL, AND I THINK YOU'RE HEADED
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. UM I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE, UM THE
POINTS MADE BY OUR OPPOSITION.
CERTAINLY COUNTY CORRECTIONS
DOES NOT OPERATE IN THE SAME WAY
THAT STATES DO OR STATE
CORRECTION DOES SO I DO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SHERIFF'S
POSITION, ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
COUNTIES. WHAT THE SHERIFF SAYS
IS THE SHERIFF GOES AND
COMMUNITY, SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT VOICE AT
THE TABLE, PARTICULARLY SINCE
WE'RE IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM
STATEWIDE. I THINK IT HELPS TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
FROM OUR CALIFORNIA WELFARE
ASSOCIATION AS WELL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS AS,
UM, HOW THE IMPLEMENTATION IS
GOING TO IMPACT CURRENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL AIM AND I
HAVE HEARD YOU SAY THAT YOU
WOULD TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE TIMELINES ARE CLOSE BUT NOT
OVERLAPPING TO A POINT THAT
OVERBURDENS THE SYSTEM SO WE'VE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT THAT. UM, SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY AND HOLD THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE MY VOTE. IF WE DON'T GET
TO A GOOD PLACE BY THE TIME IT
HITS THE FLOOR, SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. RIGHT? DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? OH, THANK YOU, UH, MOVED
BY MENJIVAR. ASSISTANT POLICE
CALL THE ROLL. MY APOLOGIES THAT
BECKER, PLEASE, PLEASE CLOSE NÓ
PROBLEM. IT WAS A LONG
DISCUSSION, BUT A ROBUST
DISCUSSION. I APPRECIATE, UM,
ALL THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES, AND, UM, UM FROM THE
SUPPORT AND THE OPPOSITION, YOU
KNOW, I. I DO THINK THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. UM I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS IS A MORAL
MEASURE, BUT ALSO A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE. WE KNOW THAT COW FRESH
IS UNDERUTILIZED IN, UH,
CALIFORNIA AND, UM, AND JUST
STARTING THAT PAPER THAT WORK
EARLIER SO THAT WE CAN GET
PEOPLE. CAR PRESSURE RIGHT WHEN
THEY EXIT, UM AND GIVEN THAT
ADDITIONAL LEG UP TO GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET. WE'VE SEEN OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE IT. WE'VE SEEN
ORANGE COUNTY CAN DO IT. I
BELIEVE WE CAN DO IT. BUT I DO
WANT IT TO BE IMPLEMENT. I DON'T
WANT TO SET UP ON YOU KNOW, UH,
UNREASONABLE TIMELINES FOR SURE,
SO HAPPY TO KEEP WORKING ON THE
TIMELINES AND HAPPY TO KEEP
WORKING ON THE MAKEUP OF THE, UM
OF THE WORK GROUP AS WELL AND
WITHOUT A STRESSFUL AS FOR OUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR
BECKER AND AS YOU AND I
DISCUSSED, ORANGE COUNTY IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE RURAL CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S WHY LOOKING AT SOME
OF THESE OTHER AREAS AND TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. OUR
OPPOSITION'S POINTS IS
IMPERATIVE. OK MOVED BY SENATOR
MANJAR ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FOUR. S¼ B
1254 DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GILL HØI ALVARADO GILL
I A èC B. BLAKESPEAR BLAKESPEAR
I MENJIVAR MENJIVAR I WAHAB
WAHAB IY. 40 AND THAT BILL IS
OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. UM SENATOR NILO. WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING. UM, I DO HAVE A WITNESS
THAT NEEDS TO BE OUT OF HERE IN
ABOUT 1015 MINUTES, SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO OUT OF TURN? UM,
JUST BRIEFLY. IF THAT IS OK.
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A SHORT
AND, UM BRIEF BILL.
WELCOME SENATOR ALVARADO. A.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO HEAR SENATE
BILL. OOPS. SB 1197. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND OUR FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. UH, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1197. THIS IS A BILL
THAT WILL CLARIFY THAT IN-HOME
RESPITE SERVICES PROVIDED BY OUR
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE AVAILABLE
TO RELATIVE AND NON RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS OF CHILDREN RECEIVING
A F Dð èC THAT IS THE AID TO
FAMILIES WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN
AND FOSTER CARE BENEFITS. THIS
INCLUDES EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS, RESOURCE FAMILIES
TRIBALLY APPROVED. HOMES AND
CAREGIVERS OF NON MINOR
DEPENDENT, ENSURING ACCESS TO
IN-HOME RESPITE SERVICES FOR
RELATIVE AND NON-RELATIVE
CAREGIVERS RECEIVING A F Dð èC
F èC BENEFITS IS ESSENTIAL TO
FULFILLING THIS DUTY AND
PROVIDING A SAFETY NET FOR THOSE
WHO DEDICATE THEMSELVES TO
CARING FOR OUR FOSTER CHILDREN.
A REVIEW OF CURRENTLY POSTED
SERVICES. UH, SERVICE POLICIES
FROM ALL REGIONAL CENTERS FOUND
THAT AT LEAST 10 OF THE 21
REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE ISSUES
WITH EITHER THEIR PURCHASE OF
SERVICES POLICIES. RESPITE
SERVICES WITH THEIR RESPITE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT TOOLS OR WITH
BOTH. ADDITIONALLY SOME REGIONAL
CENTERS TREAT THIS BENEFIT
STRICTLY AS A GENERIC RESOURCE
AND PRECLUDE ANYONE WHO RECEIVES
THE AFDC FC BENEFITS FROM BEING
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE RESPITE AS
LEGISLATORS. WE HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL DUTY TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS. THIS
INCLUDES CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
AND THOSE CAREGIVERS. EXCESSIVE
ACCESS TO IN HOME RESPITE
SERVICES SHOULD NOT BE
CONTINGENT ON THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE CAREGIVER AND THE
FOSTER CHILD. STATE LEGISLATORS
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY, PROMOTE
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS IN ACCESS TO
SOCIAL SERVICES, REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE CAREGIVER IS A
RELATIVE OR A NON RELATIVE. WITH
ME HERE TODAY, I HAVE TO TESTIFY
, ROSE FREE HART FROM CHILDREN'S
LAW CENTER AND ERIC HARRIS FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS, CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
IS WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR, MADAM VICE CHAIR
AND FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY TODAY. MY NAME IS
ERIC HARRIS AND I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA AS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT PROTECTS AND ADVANCES THE
RIGHTS OF DISABLED CALIFORNIANS.
WE ARE EXCITED TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT S¼ B 1197. 1197 A SIMPLE
YET IMPACTFUL BILL MAKES IT
EASIER FOR SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST MARGINALIZED YOUTH TO LIVE
IN HOMES OF THEIR OWN. NOT
COSTLY, NOT COSTLY FACILITIES.
NOT CONGREGATE OR CARCERAL
SETTINGS, HOMES. IT DOES SO BY
CLARIFYING THAT CHILDREN AND NON
MINOR DEPENDENTS IN FOSTER CARE.
CANNOT BE EXCLUDED FROM
RECEIVING IN HOME RESPITE
SERVICES FUNDED BY REGIONAL
CENTERS. THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL
SUPPORT THAT GIVES UM, THAT
GIVES CARETAKERS A BREAK AND AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES, WHICH IN TURN
RESULTS IN INCREASED PLACEMENT.
STABILITY AND BETTER OUTCOMES
FOR OUR KIDS. AS THE SENATOR
SAID SOME REGIONAL CENTERS DENY
ACCESS TO IN HOME RESPITE
SERVICES BASED ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CAREGIVER AND THE FOSTER CHILD
BELIEVING, FOR EXAMPLE, THAT
CHILDREN WHO LIVE WITH NON
RELATIVE UM RESOURCE FAMILIES
AREN'T ELIGIBLE FOR THIS BENEFIT
. OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS TREAT A
F Dð èC F èC BENEFITS, WHICH
IS A FORM OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CHILDREN WHO HAVE
BEEN PLACED IN FOSTER CARE AS A
GENERIC RESOURCE AND PRECLUDE
ANYONE WHO RECEIVES THESE
BENEFITS FROM BEING ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE RESPITE. TO BE FAIR. WE
ARE ALSO AWARE OF REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT DON'T PLACE ANY OF
THESE RESTRICTIONS ON IN HOME
RESPITE AT ALL. THEY UNDERSTAND
THE STATE'S INTENT TO ENSURE
THAT DISABLED CHILDREN HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO REMAIN IN
THEIR HOMES, WHICH IS A PRIORITY
IN BOTH THE CHILD WELFARE AND
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICE PROGRAM.
THE POINT IS THAT ACCESS TO IN
HOME RESPITE SERVICES SHOULD NOT
BE DEPENDENT ON WHETHER A CHILD
HAPPENS TO BE SERVED IN REDWOOD
COAST REGIONAL CENTER DOWN IN
SAN DIEGO OR DOWN IN SAN DIEGO,
UH, REGIONAL CENTER OR ANYWHERE
IN BETWEEN, BY CREATING MORE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS REGIONAL
CENTERS IN A WAY THAT EXPANDS TO
HOME BASED SUPPORT S¼ B 1197
WILL BUILD A MORE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM AND REDUCE THE RISK THAT
DUAL AGENCY CHILDREN END UP MORE
COSTLY AND MORE COSTLY BASED
CARE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE ON 11 ON S¼ B 1197.
THANK YOU, MISTER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS ROSIE
FREIH AND I'M, AN ATTORNEY AT
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. WE REPRESENT THE
CHILD WELFARE INVOLVED YOUTH OF
LOS ANGELES, SACRAMENTO AND
PLASTER COUNTIES AND ARE PROUD
COS SPONSORS OF SB 197. MY JOB
AT CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER IS TO
FOCUS ON HELPING OUR CLIENTS WHO
HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ACCESS SERVICES THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE SYSTEM
SERVICES LIKE RESPITE. I'M GOING
TO TELL YOU TODAY ABOUT TWO OF
MY CLIENTS WHO I'M GOING TO CALL
KEVIN AND MAURICE. THOSE ARE
FAKE NAMES, BUT THEY ARE VERY
REAL CHILDREN WHOSE EXPERIENCE I
THINK ILLUSTRATES NOT ONLY THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESPITE BUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF S¼ B 1197. KEVIN
AND MAURICE HAVE MANY THINGS IN
COMMON. THEY ARE BOTH AFRICAN
AMERICAN YOUNG MEN WHO ARE DULY
SERVED BY THE CHILD WELFARE IN
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEMS. THEY
BOTH HAVE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND REQUIRE
SUPERVISION BEYOND WHAT IS
TYPICAL FOR THEIR AGE. THEY BOTH
HAVE RELATIVES WHO LOVE THEM
DEEPLY, BUT ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM CARE AT THIS POINT
IN THEIR LIVES. THERE IS ONE
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THEM, THOUGH. WHILE THEY BOTH
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES, THEY ARE
SERVED BY TWO DIFFERENT REGIONAL
CENTERS. AND THESE AND THESE TWO
REGIONAL CENTERS INTERPRET THE
REGULATIONS AND LAW REGARDING
RESPITE DIFFERENTLY. KEVIN'S
REGIONAL CENTER TAKES THE
POSITION THAT RESPITE CAN ONLY
BE PROVIDED TO A FAMILY MEMBER
AND EXCLUDES NON RELATIVE
RESOURCE PARENTS FROM THAT
CATEGORY. THIS PRESENTED A
PROBLEM WHEN WE WERE PREPARING
FOR KEVIN'S RELEASE FROM
JUVENILE HALL. HE NEEDED A
RESOURCE HOME AND POINTING OUT
THE RESPITE WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO A POTENTIAL HOME WOULD HAVE
MADE IT EASIER TO FIND HIM. WHEN
WEST WHEN RESPITE WAS REQUESTED
FROM HIS REGIONAL CENTER. THE
REGIONAL CENTER RESPOND, DENIED
THE SERVICE BECAUSE ITS
POTENTIAL CAREGIVER, WHOEVER
THEY MAY BE WOULD NOT BE A
FAMILY MEMBER. WITHOUT THAT
SUPPORT. THE COUNTY FOUND NÓ ONE
WHEN HE LEFT JUVENILE HALL,
KEVIN WAS PLACED IN CONGREGATE
CARE WHERE HE STRUGGLED AND
EVENTUALLY RAN AWAY. I AM SORRY
TO SHARE THAT HE IS NOW BACK IN
JUVENILE HALL ON NEW CHARGES.
NOW, MAURICE. MAURICE REQUIRES
CONSTANT SUPERVISION BEYOND
NEARLY ANY CLIENT I HAVE EVER
WORKED WITH RESOURCE HOME AFTER
RESOURCE HOME TOOK HIM IN, BUT
FOUND THEMSELVES EXHAUSTED BY
THE LEVEL OF CARE REQUIRED, IN
FACT, IN ABOUT A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD, MAURICE LIVED IN 19
DIFFERENT HOMES. HIS 20TH HOME
WAS WITH A NON-RELATIVE
CAREGIVER, AND SHE WAS
STRUGGLING TO THIS CAREGIVER HER
CARE WHEN FINALLY HE WAS FOUND
ELIGIBLE FOR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES AND RESPITE STARTED,
EVEN THOUGH SHE WAS NOT A FAMILY
MEMBER. GETTING AN OCCASIONAL
BREAK IMPROVED HER PATIENTS WITH
HIS BEHAVIORS. HE HAS NOW BEEN
IN THIS HOME FOR OVER THREE
YEARS, BY FAR THE LONGEST TIME
HE HAS EVER BEEN IN ONE HOME.
RESPITE NOT ONLY GAVE THIS
CAREGIVER A MUCH NEEDED AND MUCH
DESERVED TO BREAK IT GAVE US
VULNERABLE CHILD STABILITY AND A
SENSE OF FAMILY. SB 1197 WILL
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVED YOUTH ARE NOT EXCLUDED
FROM RECEIVING RESPITE EVEN WHEN
THEY DON'T LIVE WITH A FAMILY
MEMBER OR ARE NON MINOR
DEPENDENTS. THIS WILL HELP
CHILDREN LIKE KEVIN FIND A HOME
LIKE MAURICE DEAD. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL FOR
AUTHORING THE SPELL AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS FIRE, HEART FRY HEART OVER
THE TIER WITH THE DEAN WITH THE
TÌM. NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB 1197
HERE IN ROOM 2200. AND AT THIS
TIME, JUST YOUR NAME AND YOUR
NATION AND YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, REBECA
GONZALEZ, WITH THE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. SUSANNA
KNIFFEN WITH CHILDREN NOW AND
SUPPORT. MANY KIRCHNER, WGA AND
SUPPORT TIFFANY WAITING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT KELLY
BROOKS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY LIVING NETWORK AND
SUPPORT MARK FROM DISABILITY
VOICES, UNITED AND STRONG
SUPPORT. AMY WESTLING FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT CHRISTOPHER
SANCHEZ, REPRESENTING COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT HI. MY
NAME IS ALEDO LOGIN. DARK AND
TERRORISTS VALLEY MOUNT REGIONAL
CENTER CATCHMENT AREA AND
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH GOMEZ, INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATE AND PARENT
AND STRONG SUPPORT YOUR ANKLE
AND I SUPPORT TO 1197. MARIELA
RAMOS AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MARIA FALCON AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NAME IS A
NOVELIST AND I'M SUPPORT THINK
PARADISE IS ABOUT ALL THAT AT
THE CLIENT SOFTWARE CENTER
STRONGLY SUPPORT MY NAME IS
FOCUS OF FLORES AND SUPPORT RUBY
SALDANA VIEW AMBASSADOR IN
SUPPORT. ESTRADA MAN FOR JUAN
PEREZ AND INTEGRAL DORA IS FROM
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HALLMARK
GRANADOS FROM THE NEWMAN
COMMUNITY, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT MARIA GRANADOS. I LIVE
IN NEWMAN. I SUPPORT MARIA ELENA
DÍAS, I'M SUPPORT RICARDO ARE
AGAIN AND STRONG SUPPORT. MY
NAME IS SARA LEE SOLANO AND
NIGHT LOVELY, STRONG SUPPORT
1197. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES REPORTED 1197 HERE IN
ROOM 22 HUNDRED'S SCENE AND MOVE
INTO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD?
WHAT IS THIS? IN OPPOSITION SEEN
? NONE WILL MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
ROOM 2200. SEEN NONE WILL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE MANY. SENATOR
WILL HAPPEN. I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS
FROM ALRIGHT IN THAT CASE, UM
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JUST NEED TO CLOSE. SORRY
MA'AM. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. TO ALL OF YOU WHO SHOWED UP
TODAY TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. THIS
BILL AT THIS POINT HAS NO
OPPOSITION. THE AMENDMENTS DID
ADD TRIBALLY APPROVED HOMES WE
WANTED TO RECOGNIZE OR TRIBAL
FAMILIES AS WELL. IN ADDITION TO
RESOURCE FAMILIES IN OUR CURRENT
TEXT, THANK YOU. AND I RESPECT
THE ASPIRIN. I VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR. RATHER GIRL
AND I'M SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL? FILE ITEM 11.
SB 1197 MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GIL. I
ALVARADO GUILT I KNOW. BUG ROBO
GUY SHAKESPEARE, OR I MENTION
FAR FAR. I HA PERHAPS I THAT IS
OUT 5 TO 0. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY SENATOR NEAL. OH, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENTS. WE
WILL NOW MOVE FORWARD WITH ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SENATE BILL 1463.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. EXCUSE ME,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
SB 1463, WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM, OR SDP,
BY CREATING A DEDICATED SENIOR
POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES FOCUSED
SOLELY ON THIS PROGRAM'S SUCCESS
. HAVING THIS POSITION WILL
PROVIDE FOR IMPROVED
ACCOUNTABILITY. OVER THE SUCCESS
OF STDS S D P AND REAFFIRM OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO SELF
DETERMINATION. SELF
DETERMINATION RECOGNIZES THAT
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
THE SAME RIGHT TO A AND
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT ACCOMPANY
SELF DETERMINATION AS EVERYBODY
ELSE. PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ARE ENTITLED. TWO
OPPORTUNITIES. RESPECTFUL
SUPPORT. AND THE AUTHORITY TO
ACCEPT EXCERPT EXERT CONTROL
OVER THEIR LIVES. CURRENTLY DDS
IS THREE YEARS FROM ITS 2021
TRANSITION TO THE SDP PILOT
PROGRAM INTO A STATEWIDE PROMISE
FOR THOSE THAT SEEK THE BENEFITS
OF THIS VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. YET
THE DELIVERY OF THOSE PROMISES
HAVE REALLY YET TO BE REALIZED.
LESS THAN 1% OF ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN THE PROGRAM
AND THE CURRENT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
THAT OVERSEES THE MANAGER OF SDP
IS BEING BORROWED FOR OTHER
PRIORITIES ON A SUPPOSED
TEMPORARY BASIS. THOSE FEW THAT
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE PROGRAM
WERE GENERALLY PLEASED WITH
THEIR EXPERIENCE AND OVER THREE
QUARTERS OF THEM WOULD RECOMMEND
SDP TO OTHERS. THIS SATISFACTION
NOTWITHSTANDING, PARTICIPANTS
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
AND CHALLENGES AND THE PROGRAM
COULD BE IMPROVED BY REDUCING
COMPLEXITY AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON THE
PARTICIPANT. THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT THIS DEDICATED
POSITION CAN ADDRESS. SB 1463
WILL PROVIDE FOR IMPROVED
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER THE SUCCESS
OF SDP. AND REAFFIRM AGAIN
REAFFIRM THE STATE'S COMMITMENT.
TO SELF DETERMINATION. WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS JUDY MARKS ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED AND RUBY SALDANA, PARENT
OF THREE SDP PARTICIPANTS, RIGHT
. THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
PLEASE. JUST RESTATE YOUR NAME
AND BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, SENATOR. MY
NAME IS JUDY MARK AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED. WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION
LED BY PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. WHO
WROTE AND ADVOCATED FOR THE
ORIGINAL SELF DETERMINATION LAW
THAT WAS PASSED IN 2013. I'M
ALSO THE PARENT OF A SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM
PARTICIPANT WHO IS MOVING INTO
HIS OWN PLACE IN THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS, THANKS TO THE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED THROUGH THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM, AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB 1463. WE
WANT TO THANK SENATOR NILO FOR
HIS LONG STANDING SUPPORT FOR
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND FOR
AUTHORING THIS LEGISLATION THAT
COULD HAVE A PROFOUND EFFECT ON
IMPROVING THE SELF. TERMINATION
PROGRAM FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IN 2013. I REMEMBER TESTIFYING
AT THIS EXACT COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT SB 468. THE SELF
DETERMINATION LAW ARE AUTHOR
SENATOR EMERSON CHAMPIONED THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT PROVIDED
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THE FREEDOM OF AN
AUTHORITY TO HAVE CONTROL OVER
THEIR LIVES TO HAVE CONTROL OVER
WHO SERVES THEM AND WHO SUPPORTS
THEM EVERY DAY. THE PROGRAM HAS
SUCH GREAT POTENTIAL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AFTER THAT
TIME SIGNED UP TO ENROLL FOR
THIS PROGRAM. BUT 10 YEARS LATER
, ONLY 1% OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE TO BE PART OF THE
PROGRAM ARE ACTUALLY IN IT. IT
IS CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
ENROLL. THE PROGRAM HAS BECOME
OVERLY BUREAUCRATIC AND
INCONSISTENTLY IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS THE 21 REGIONAL CENTERS.
PEOPLE DESPERATELY WANT TO BE
PART OF IT, BUT IT JUST SEEMS
OVERWHELMING. AND WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES HAS THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAM'S SUCCESS THUS FAR, THIS
HAS NOT HAPPENED. SB 1463
RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR A
DEDICATED SENIOR POSITION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES FOCUSED SOLELY ON THE
PROGRAM'S SUCCESS. IT WILL BE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR, WHICH
WILL BRING MUCH NEEDED ATTENTION
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS. POSITION
WILL BE CONFIRMED BY YOU BY THE
SENATE, WHICH ENSURES A
CONFIRMATION PROCESS THAT
PROVIDES A FORUM FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE SERVED BY THE SYSTEM AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO PROVIDE INPUT.
WE BELIEVE THAT SB 1463 IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM CAN
CONTINUE TO CHANGE LIVES LIKE MY
SONS. THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS RUDY SALDANA, AND I AM AN
AMBASSADOR FOR DISABILITY BOYS
UNITED, THE SPONSOR OF SB 1463.
MY ENGLISH IS NOT VERY WELL
WHERE I'M GONNA TRY MY BEST. I
AM THE PARENT OF THREE CHILDREN
WHO ARE PARTICIPANTS,
PARTICIPANTS AND SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THIS
PROGRAM HAS CHANGED ALL OF ALL
THEIR OF THEIR LIVES, BUT
SOMETIMES IT IS VERY HARD TO
MAKE IT WORK. I HELP OTHERS
SPEAK SPANISH PARENTS WHO WANT
THEIR CHILDREN TO GO INTO SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THIS IS
PRETTY EVERYONE EXPERIENCES
WORRYING IS THE P, BUT IT IS
ESPECIALLY HARD FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. WE BECOME VERY
DISCOURAGED BY THE PROCESS AND
THE SYSTEMS. THERE ARE MANY
TIMES WHEN I HAVE TRIED TO GET
HELP FROM DBS FOR MY OWN
CHILDREN OR FOR OTHER FAMILIES
AND SDP. THERE IS THERE IS A
POSITION OF THE CPM BUSSMANN
PERSON. AND WHEN WE REACH OUT TO
THEM, WE ARE NOT GETTING THE
RESOURCE WE NEED. THIS IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
POWER. THE ONLY THING THAT THEY
BUST ME CAN DO IS MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
IMPROVE THE PROGRAM. THEY
ACTUALLY CAN NOT MADE THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS HAPPEN IS BEFORE 63
GIVES MY COMMUNITY AT CHANCE, A
CHANCE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PROGRAM THAT CAN SAVE LIVES AND
FAMILIES BECAUSE THERE WILL BE A
SENIOR LEVEL STAFF AT THE D. S.
WHO DOES HAVE THE POWER IT WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS SOME
WHAT I D D S WHO COMPLETELY
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE SUCCESS OF
SDP. WHEN WHEN THE SENATE
CONFIRMS THIS PERSON, LATINO
FAMILIES WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT
WHATEVER THE STUDIES ARE BEING
IMPROVED OR THINGS ARE NOT
GETTING BETTER. THIS BILL WILL
HOPE HOPEFULLY MAKE THE SOVIET
DOMINATION PROGRAM WORK MUCH
BETTER SO THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON
IMPROVING OUR CHILDREN'S LIFE
RATHER THAN IMPROVING PROGRAMS
THAT SHOULD BE EASY TO USE. IN
ADDITION, I HAVE ALREADY
EXPERIENCED RETALIATION AND
INTIMIDATION PERSONALLY, NOT
FROM THE REGIONAL CENTER, BUT
BUT OTHERS, AND I'M NOT AFRAID
TO SAY THAT WHOEVER GET IZATION
OR INSTITUTION WHO OPPOSED THE
SPONSOR BILLS FROM THE VIEW AND
I C C WORKS AGAINST THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY SUPPOSED TO
SERVE BECAUSE WE ARE THE REAL
COMMUNITY UNITED AND INTEGRATED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
AND WE WILL NOW PROCEED. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND THEN SHARE
YOUR POSITION, PLEASE. FALCON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I DON'T
KNOW. MELISSA. I SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ELIZABETH GOMEZ. INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE,
INDEPENDENT FACILITATOR AND
SUPPORT YOU. SEND IT TO
INTEGRATE TO AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANKLE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DOOR.
CONTRERAS AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIA ELENA
RAMOS IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. WHAT'S THE FLORES IN
SUPPORT? LODGES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OMAR GRANADOS, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIA GRANADOS HAS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JONATHAN
GRANADOS. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. RICARDO OR AGAIN A
STRONGEST SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SOLANO MEMBER FROM THE SEA.
STRONG SUPPORT 1467 1463. I'M
SORRY. YES THANK YOU, PEREZ AND
STRONG SUPPORT LAST YEAR. MARIA
ELENA DIAZ AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH. ALRIGHT WE WILL NOW BE
ABLE TO HEAR FROM LEAD WITNESSES
AND OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION? ME SEE NONE. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SHARE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL?
SEEING NONE BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
MEMBER'S QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MOVED BY SENATOR SHOW BOGUE.
RIGHT, RIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
SENATOR NEAL? OH, YES. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. EVER SINCE THE
LETTERMAN ACT OF ROUGHLY 50
YEARS AGO. THE POLICY OF THIS
STATE HAS BEEN TO PROVIDE THOSE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD
SUCCESSFUL AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES
AND THE REGIONAL CENTERS WERE
ESTABLISHED TO ASSIST THAT IN
OUR VARIOUS REGIONAL AREAS. THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THE
STATE HAS ALSO MADE A COMMITMENT
TO THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM, WHICH FURTHERS THAT
VERY OPPORTUNITY AND WE MUST
SUPPORT IT ON BEHALF OF THESE,
UM PARTICULARLY NEEDING MEMBERS
OF OUR STATE CITIZENS OF OUR
STATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, UM BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR JOE
BOTH SYSTEM. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM SEVEN. SB 1463
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL, I ALVARADO GIL. I
KOBO KOBO GUY. SHAKESPEARE
SHAKESPEARE. I MENJIVAR JAFAR, I
WAHA WAHA. I OKAY? THE VOTE IS 5
TO 0 IN THAT BILL IS OUT. THANK
YOU. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION. THANK YOU FOR ALL OF THE
SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU. SO WE
HAVE THREE MORE BILLS. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE WILL MOVE
FORWARD WITH SENATOR MENJIVAR,
THEN SENATOR BLAKE SPIRIT AND
SIMILAR OCHOA BOTH THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
SENATOR MENJIVAR. DO YOU HAVE
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT? OKAY,
WE'LL ASK THEM TO COME FORWARD
AND GET SETTLED. AND WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY WELL HERE. FILE
NUMBER EIGHT SENATE BILL 1281.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION ON SUB
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. BUT
BEFORE WE GET INTO IT, I WANNA I
WANT TO NOTE THAT I WILL BE
AMENDING THE BILL TO CORRECT TO
DRAFTING ERA STATED IN COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS PAGE 12 AS AS WELL AS
ACCEPTING THE CHAIRS AMENDMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A TROUBLE
LASER AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. YOU HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS WE ALL HEARD IN THE
PREVIOUS BILL CONVERSATION THAT
ONE OF THOSE AMAZING PROGRAMS IS
THE STUFF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
YOU HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS
WITNESSES, SIMILAR STORIES THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR HERE AS
WELL. SUB DETERMINATION PROGRAM
HELPS INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BY
FORMING A SUB CUSTOMIZED PLAN
WITH SERVICES AND SUPPORT. WE
SHOULD NOT BE COPYING AND PASTE
THESE SERVICES FOR EVERY
INDIVIDUAL. EVERY INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS. SERVICES NEED TO BE
TAILORED AND THEIR WANTS NEEDS
TO BE ALSO TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. IN FACT, MADAM
CHAIR HAS TO BE PILOT PROGRAM
WAS CREATED WITH THE PRIMARY
GOAL TO WORK IN RURAL AREAS.
HAVING THE SNP MEANT THAT THE
ROYAL FAMILIES COULD RECRUIT
MEMBERS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AND NOT
HAVE TO RELY ON REGIONAL CENTER
VENDORS WHO DIDN'T WANT TO WORK
IN AREAS WHERE THERE WERE FEW
POTENTIAL CLIENTS AS THE P
PARTICIPANTS HAVE REPORTED
POSITIVE GROWTH IN AREAS SUCH AS
SELF AWARENESS, RESPONSIBILITY,
MENTAL HEALTH, COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION, EMPLOYMENT AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. BECAUSE WHEN IT
GOES WHEN WE SEE THIS, WE SEE
INDIVIDUALS GO THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM. IT WORKS AND WE HAVE
POSITIVE RESULTS AT THE END. WE
JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO THIS
PROGRAM. SO TO THAT THE STATE
COUNCIL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES RECENTLY FOUND THAT
DESPITE APART PARTICIPANTS
FAVORING SCP, THERE ARE MANY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS AND
HURDLES THAT CAME ALONG WITH THE
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY THERE WERE
REPORTED CONCERNS ABOUT
INEQUITIES IN THE PROGRAM SUCH
AS RACIAL DISPARITIES AND HOW
SDP WAS BEING IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
REGIONAL CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT OLD,
TREATED EQUAL. SPEECH OF ANYONE
SEEKS TO ELIMINATE THE CONCERNS
AND BARRIERS BY REQUIRING THAT
DDS ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE
STANDARDIZED AND STREAMLINED
PROCEDURES FOR ENROLLMENT,
INDIVIDUALIZED BUDGETS.
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SERVICES
ACCESS IS SELF DIRECTED
TRANSITION SERVICES IN A CLIENT
SPENDING PLAN. WE WANT TO ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE RESPECTING
THE PARTICIPANTS PROVIDER
CHOICE. WE WANT TO ENSURE THE
INDIVIDUALS AND TRAIN STB HAVE
ACCESS TO TRANSITION SUPPORT
FROM TRUSTED PARTNERS, AND WE
WANT TO CLARIFY EMPLOYER BURDEN
AND WHAT COST FMS CAN AND CANNOT
PASS ON TO PARTICIPANTS
REQUIRING THAT FMS PROVIDE
TIMELY PAYMENTS TO PROVIDERS
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
OFTEN TIMES THE BURDEN IS PLACED
ON THE PARTICIPANT VERSUS THE
ACTUAL REGIONAL CENTERS WHO'S
PROVIDING THAT ACTUAL PAYMENT.
PARTICIPANTS HAVE NO SAY IN
PAYMENTS GOING OUT. LASTLY, WE
WANT TO REQUIRE DDS TO INCLUDE
THE ASSESSMENT AND ADEQUACY OF M
S. F M. F M S PROVIDERS AT EACH
REGIONAL CENTER IN THEIR ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
CURRENTLY LATINOS COMPROMISE
COMPRISE 40% OF PEOPLE SERVED BY
REGIONAL CENTERS, BUT ONLY 24%
OF THOSE PARTICIPATING SDP
COMPARED TO WHY PARTICIPANTS WHO
ONLY MAKE UP 20% OF THOSE SERVED
BY REGIONAL CENTERS, BUT 36% OF
THOSE THROUGH SDP, THESE REPORTS
WERE HELPING SURE THAT BIPOD
COMMUNITY RECEIVED THE SERVICES
IN EQUITABLE MANNER. SO TO THAT,
I'M SURE I'D LIKE TO TURN TO MY
TWO WITNESSES HERE TO TESTIFY ON
THE NEED OF SB 1281 1 THAT WE'VE
JUST HEARD. JUDY MARK AND THEN
ELIZABETH GOMEZ. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. BRUCE. PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JUDY MARK AGAIN FROM DISABILITY
VOICES. UNITED DVU IS A CO
SPONSOR OF SB 1281. AND WE
WANTED DEEPLY THANK SENATOR
MENJIVAR FOR YOUR EXTRAORDINARY
LEADERSHIP ARE OFFERING THIS
BILL AND EVERYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE DONE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. WE
FEEL IT. FEEL IT FROM YOU. AND
WE JUST WANTED YOU TO KNOW THAT
UM, WE AS AS I STATED BEFORE OUR
WERE FOUNDED BY THE FOLKS WHO
GOT THE BILL PASSED ORIGINALLY
IN 2013, AND WE KNEW THAT SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM HAD GREAT
PROMISE. BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE
DELVED DEEP INTO WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE. WHERE ARE THE
BARRIERS THAT PEOPLE ARE FACING?
AND THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE
BIGGEST ONES. IT DOESN'T ADDRESS
EVERY BARRIER, BUT IT ADDRESSES
THE BIGGEST ONE. BIGGEST ONES
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT WILL BE
ABLE TO BRING ABOUT EQUITY
WITHIN THE PROGRAM. UM SB 1281
REQUIRES DDS TO ESTABLISH
STREAMLINED AND SIMPLIFIED
PROCEDURES SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
MORE EASILY ENROLL AND STAY IN
THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. EACH OF
THE 21 REGIONAL CENTERS HAVE
THEIR OWN WAY OF RUNNING THE SDP
AND IT CAN'T PEOPLE MOVE FROM
REGIONAL SENATOR REGIONAL CENTER
AND IT'S REALLY QUITE A PROBLEM.
IT PREVENTS MANY PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO DO NOT HAVE
FAMILY SUPPORT AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR FROM PARTICIPATING IN A
PROGRAM THAT CAN CHANGE THEIR
LIFE. NOT ONLY CAN CHANGE THEIR
LIVES, BUT IT CAN CHANGE THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
OUT THERE SUPPORTING THEM. SB
1281 ALSO CLARIFIES THE RULES
FOR FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT
SERVICES, OR FMS S, WHICH HAS
REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT PARTICIPANTS THAT THE
CURRENT RULES LEAVE IT UP TO THE
FMS SO THAT THEY ARE TAKING A
LOT OF THE MONEY THAT PEOPLE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE USING FOR THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THE BILL
STATE EXACTLY WHAT COSTS THE FMS
CAN CHARGE THE PARTICIPANT AND
ONCE THEY CAN'T CHARGE THE
PARTICIPANT. FINALLY WE BELIEVE
THAT SB 1281 WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE MAJOR BARRIERS IN THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM SO
THAT EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR RACE, ETHNICITY, LANGUAGE,
OR WHERE THEY LIVE, CAN HAVE THE
FREEDOM AND AUTHORITY THAT
PEOPLE WITHOUT DISABILITIES
EXPERIENCE EVERY DAY. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN GRANJA
BRASIL. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
GOMEZ AND I AM THE PROUD MOTHER
OF OSCAR ANTONIO, A YOUNG ADULT
WITH DOWN SYNDROME IN HIS THIRD
YEAR IN SOUTH DETERMINATION. I'M
ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. LATINO. UM MOSTLY
SPANISH SPEAKING COMMUNITY THAT
WE HELP AND WE COLLABORATE TO
SUPPORT, UM, TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEX SYSTEM. THAT SERVE OUR
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. TRADITIONAL SYSTEM
OF THE REGIONAL CENTER ISN'T
WORKING FOR MANY OF THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. WE FACE OVERWHELMING
DISPARITIES THAT DON'T SEEM TO
BE IMPROVING SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM HAS BEEN LIFE CHANGING
FOR MANY LATINO FAMILIES WERE
ABLE TO HIRE STAFF. THAT WE
TRUST AND UNDERSTAND OUR CULTURE
WHERE ABLE TO GET THE HELP TO
START MY CRANIUM PRICES RUN BY
OUR ADULT CHILDREN WERE ABLE TO
ACCESS INCLUSIVE PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WERE ABLE TO HELP
WITH SERVICES THAT OUR LOVED
ONES NEED TO REMAIN IN THE
FAMILY HOME FOR THE FIRST TIME.
YEAH BUT UNFORTUNATELY, I'M HERE
TO SAY THAT THE LATINO COMMUNITY
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE PROGRAM,
THERE ARE MANY REASONS FOR THIS,
INCLUDING THAT MANY LATINO
FAMILIES HAVE NEVER EVEN HEARD
ABOUT THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM AND EVEN IF THEY HAVE
THE OFTEN GET DISCOURAGED FROM
PARTICIPATING BY THE REGIONAL
CENTERS, SAYING THAT IT IS TOO
HARD LATINOS ALSO START. UM
LATINOS ALSO STARTED OUT WITH
DISPARITIES BY GETTING 50% OF
THE SERVICES THAT WHITES RECEIVE
WITH SUCH LOW OR EVEN KNOW
BUDGETS. WE HAVE TO MAKE CLAIMS
OF UNMET NEEDS IN THE
TRADITIONAL SYSTEM, WHICH DELAYS
AND PREVENTS OUR PARTICIPATION.
IS A CO SPONSOR OF SB 1281.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BREAK DOWN
THE BARRIERS SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITY CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM. THE BILL REQUIRES
EQUITABLE ENROLLMENT BY RACE,
ETHNICITY, WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. SB 1281 ALLOWS
PARTICIPANTS TO BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE WHO THEY WANT TO HELP
THEM TRANSITION INTO THE SDP.
WEL I SEE HELPS MANY FAMILIES
TRANSITION INTO THE SDP PROGRAM
RECENTLY, DS CHANGES REQUIRE US
TO BE REGIONAL CENTER VENDORS,
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST. AND COMPROMISE ARE
NEUTRAL POSITION THAT HELPS
PROVIDE IN HELPING THE COMMUNITY
IS B 1281 ALSO AFFIRMS THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO CHOOSE THEIR
SERVICES AND PROVIDERS WITH
CLEAR GUIDELINES. AND NO SECOND
GUESS BY THE REGIONAL CENTERS
AND INFAMOUS ALL OF THE
ASSESSMENTS AND COMPLICATIONS BY
THE ORIGINAL CENTERS WILL BE
REMOVE. WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
MINCHIN BARRED FOR HER
INCREDIBLE SUPPORT AND FOR
AUTHORING AS B 1281. SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM IS CERTAIN
TO MAKE OUR LIVES BETTER IF WE
CAN JUST GIVE IT A CHANCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE WILL HELP OPEN
IT UP TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION, PLEASE. YEAH. ERIC
HARRIS WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ERIN CARRUTHERS WITH THE
STATE COUNCIL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AUTHORS OF THE
EVALUATION CITED BY THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND
SUPPORT AMY WESTLING ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT SPONSORS
, THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
AUTHOR STAFF. THANK YOU. WHAT'S
THE FLORENCE? CC I SUPPORT THE
BILL. 1281. THANK YOU. OMAR
GRANADOS, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU. MARIA
GRANADOS. I SUPPORT YEAH, THANK
YOU. JONATHAN GRANADOS. I
STRONGLY SUPPORT DRIVING AROUND
HELL. I SUPPORT THANK YOU DOOR.
CONTRERAS THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT AS SPEED
1281. THANK YOU. MARIELLA RAMOS,
MY MOTHER OF A CHILD WITH UM I D
D AND I'M VERY, VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF 11. I'VE S B 1281.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
SARA LEE SOLANO. AND I'M PART OF
IT. I HAVE MY SON, RICARDO. HE
IT'S PART OF THIS, UM THIS
PROGRAM IS THE P AND I STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. 1281 THANK
YOU SO MUCH. EVERYONE D BèC,
SENATOR ABSTINENCE TO HEAVEN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
RICARDO ARGUING AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MARIA ELENA
DÍAS SUPPORT TESTABLE TODAY.
DETERMINATION. RIGHT. THANK YOU.
SEND IT TO MY TWO KIDS. UM FOUR
YEARS ALREADY AND SO
DETERMINATION, AND IT'S A LIFE
CHANGING FOR THEM. AND WE WOULD
LIKE EVERYONE, TO BE HONEST.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE LOVE
YOU SEE ANOTHER THANK YOU.
SALDANA AMBASSADOR IN UM, ALSO
APPARENT OF THREE KIDS AND
SOVIET DOMINATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I KNOW
UNLESS I MR AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MERIEL FALCON DETERMINATION
YESTERDAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MY NAME IS JUAN PEREZ. I
SUPPORT SB 1281. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ESTRADA
PEREZ TERMINATION TERMINATION
BOSS BOTH DEVICE COMMUNICATION
SUPPORT. GRACIAS. GRACIAS. HI MY
NAME IS EVELYN SOLORIO. AND I
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALRIGHT WE'LL NOW MOVE FORWARD
TO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
SEEN DONE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. WE'LL MOVE IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY MOTION BY
SENATOR WAHAB PERHAPS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR MENTIONED
ARE I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME OUT FOR
THE THREE BILLS WHO I THINK THEY
GOT THEIR MONEY'S WORTH OR
COMING UP AND GIVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT, WHICH IS GRACES, BUT WE
NEED IN STANDING PROTECTIVENESS,
CHAD, WHOSE VOICE IS THIS ONE
POINT FOR US TO HEAR THE VOICES
OF HOW THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO
IMPACT, YOU KNOW, WANT TO SHARE
A REALLY DISTURBING STORY THAT
WE HEARD IN SUB THREE OUR MOM
THAT WAS ASKING FOR SERVICES OR
LATINA MOM AND I WAS TOLD THAT
SHE IS A BAD MOM. BECAUSE SHE
CAME AND ASPIRIN ASSISTANCE AND
HELP. THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HEARING
ACROSS REGIONAL CENTERS WHERE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, DEPENDING ON
THEIR BACKGROUNDS ARE BEING
TREATED DIFFERENT. WE'RE A STATE
OF ENTITLEMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE EVERY
PROJECT OR PROGRAM WE BRING
FORWARD IN CALIFORNIA HAS THE
INTENT THAT WE'VE WE'VE PUT IN
IT AND IT REACHES EVERY SINGLE
PERSON. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, AND I, TOO AM
A MEMBER OF THE SENATOR MENJIVAR
FAN CLUB. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BILL MOVES BY SENATOR WAHAB,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM.
EIGHT SB 1281. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. ALVARADO GUILT I
ALVARADO GIL I VOGUE DÍAS SPEAR
SPEAR. I MEAN, JAFAR JAFAR, I
HA! HUH? BYE. IT IS 50. AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. CONGRATULATIONS
SENATOR. HEY SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR
WILL BE HEARING ITEM NUMBER NINE
SENATE BILL 1401. DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES HERE WITH YOU
TODAY? OKAY, WE'LL ASK THEM TO
COME FORWARD, PLEASE. SO WE'RE
READY TO PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. I APPRECIATE YOU
STAYING AFTER FIVE AND TO
EVERYBODY WHO'S STILL HERE AS
WELL. I'M PLEASED TO AUTHOR AND
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY S B 1401,
WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE U. S
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE. WE HAVE A
CRITICAL SHORTAGE OF CHILDCARE
OPTIONS IN CALIFORNIA AND IN THE
UNITED STATES. THE UNITED STATES
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
ESTIMATES THAT 100,000 PEOPLE
EACH MONTH MISS WORK BECAUSE OF
CHILDCARE PROBLEMS. THE STRUGGLE
TO FIND CHILDCARE IS EVEN
GREATER FOR MILITARY FAMILIES
AND MOVING EVERY FEW YEARS MEANS
STARTING THE SEARCH ALL OVER
AGAIN. RECOGNIZING THAT
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CHILDCARE IS
ESSENTIAL FOR MORALE, MISSION
READINESS AND RETENTION. THE U.
S MILITARY OFFERS SEVERAL
OPTIONS, INCLUDING FAMILY
CHILDCARE, WHICH IS CERTIFIED IN
HOME CHILDCARE. 87% OF FAMILY,
CHILDCARE OR FCC PROVIDERS
CERTIFIED BY THE U. S DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE. OUR MILITARY SPOUSES
, THE D O D ESTIMATES NEARLY A
50% SHORTAGE OF S FCC PROVIDERS
NECESSARY TO MEET DEMAND AND HAS
IDENTIFIED THAT ONE WAY TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM IS TO WAVE
STATE LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS FOR
FCC PROVIDERS WHO ARE ALREADY
CERTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE. THE DIODE CONSIDERS
THIS A STATE POLICY PRIORITY,
AND SEVERAL STATES HAVE ALREADY
APPROVED THIS WAIVER. FCC
PROVIDERS ARE LIMITED TO NO MORE
THAN SIX CHILDREN UNDER EIGHT
YEARS OLD OR NO MORE THAN EIGHT
CHILDREN WERE ALL OUR SCHOOL
AGED CERTIFIED FCC PROVIDERS
UNDERGO STRINGENT BACKGROUND
CHECKS AND SAFETY INSPECTIONS.
AND THEY MUST COMPLETE 40 HOURS
OF TRAINING BEFORE THEY CAN
BEGIN AND AT LEAST 24 HOURS
ONGOING TRAINING PER YEAR. THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE SIMILAR TO OR
GREATER THAN THOSE REQUIRED FOR
STATE LICENSURE. FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS ONLY UNDERGOES 16
HOURS OF TRAINING. THIS BILL
HELPS ADDRESS THE CURRENT
SHORTAGE OF CHILDCARE BY
ELIMINATING AN UNNECESSARY
REGULATORY HURDLE IN CALIFORNIA
FOR FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
SERVING MILITARY PERSONNEL THAT
TAKE TIME AND MONEY. FURTHER A
STATE LICENSURE WAIVER MEANS
THESE MILITARY SPOUSES CAN START
EARNING INCOME MUCH FASTER
WITHOUT NEEDING TO COMPLETE
REDUNDANT LICENSURE REQUIREMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA BY CREATING NEW
MILITARY CHILDCARE SPOTS. SP
1401 WILL ALSO HELP ALLEVIATE
WAIT LIST FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AS FEWER MILITARY FAMILIES WILL
NEED TO USE CIVILIAN OPTIONS.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE VERONICA
VIDEO ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE NAVY. THANK
YOU FOR COMING. THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED. WHEN YOU ARE
READY. YOU HAVE APPROXIMATELY
TWO MINUTES. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
VERONICA VIDEO. AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACTIVE MILITARY
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA, AS WELL
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE,
WHO, UNFORTUNATELY, COULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY, SENATOR MENTIONED SB
1401 WOULD EXEMPT YOU'D
CERTIFIED PROVIDERS LIVING OFF A
MILITARY INSTALLATION FROM STATE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS, MAKING
IT EASIER FOR PROVIDERS BY
REDUCING THE BURDEN OF OBTAINING
STATE SPECIFIC LICENSE SIRS WHEN
THEY ARE ALREADY CERTIFIED BY D
O. D. TAKING CARE OF SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
REMAINS A TOP PRIORITY OF DODD
CENTER, AND IT'S AT THE CENTER
OF THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
STRATEGY. THE DEPARTMENT
ESTABLISHED A FAMILY CHILDCARE
OR FCC PROGRAM TO EXPAND
CHILDCARE AVAILABILITY AND TO
ASSIST IN MEETING THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF MILITARY FAMILIES. THE
FCC PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF
QUALITY AND SAFETY ARE MET AND
TRACK FAMILY CHILDCARE HOMES.
THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS IS
WIDELY RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF THE
MOST STRINGENT IN THE COUNTRY.
STANDARD SET BY THE D, O D AND
THE MILITARY SERVICES ENSURE
STRICT OVERSIGHT OF SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO INCLUDE BACKGROUND
CHECKS, MONTHLY INSPECTIONS AND
UNANNOUNCED VISITS. ACCORDING TO
OUR D O D. STATE LIAISON FOR
DIODE CERTIFIED PROVIDERS
SERVING ONLY D O D ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES OFF BASE. THEO
MAINTAINS FULL OVERSIGHT AND
DISCIPLINARY RESPONSIBILITIES.
MILITARY FAMILIES NATIONWIDE
FACE SHORTAGES OF CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS. IN THE SAN DIEGO
METRO AREA ALONE. THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY 2600 CHILDREN
CURRENTLY ON THE WAITLIST FOR ON
BASE CHILD DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
ONE WAY TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE
IS BY CERTIFYING MORE FCC
PROVIDERS. SB 1401 WOULD ALLOW
FCC PROVIDERS WHO WORK
IMMEDIATELY AFTER BEING
CERTIFIED, INSPECTED AND
APPROVED BY A NEW INSTALLATION
COMMANDER TO PROVIDE CARE TO THE
CHILDREN OF MILITARY FAMILIES.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT EFFORTS CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE TO SUPPORT OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT THE POLICY REFLECTED AND
SP 1401 AND WOULD ESPECIALLY
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR FOR LEADING THIS EFFORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. NAME, AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION. AMANDA CURCIO
AND C. W J IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, AMANDA. OKAY? OKAY WE WILL
THEN MOVE TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ANYONE WISHING TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE AND
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL C. NONE
OF THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SHARE THEIR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. OKAY
ALRIGHT. WE'LL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. SENATOR COBURG LOVE
THIS BILL. I BEAT ME TO IT, BUT
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO MOVE THIS
BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE AND
WOULD LOVE TO ASK TO BE A AUTHOR
. UM WHEN AND IF POSSIBLE, AS
THE BILL CONTINUES, WE WILL BE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT WILL MAKE
A NOTE. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SENATOR BLAKE
SPEAR VIEW HAVE HAVE GOT A LOT
OF FANS ON THIS BILL. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT, UM
THAT YOU ADDRESS THE COMMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF THE
CLARITY OF JURISDICTION AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO INVESTIGATE,
SHOULD A FEDERALLY CERTIFIED
PROVIDER OPERATE OFF MILITARY
BASE. BECAUSE THE CURRENT LAW
SAYS THAT THE STATE MAY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL LICENSING WITH YOUR
BILL THAT WOULD ELIMINATE THAT.
MAY COULD YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
TO THE REFERENCE TO FEDERAL
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS AND HOW
THAT WOULD BE ADDRESSED? I NEED
TO CHECK WITH MY STAFF ARE ON
THAT BEFORE I ANSWER THIS
QUESTION COURSE.
I'M GOING TO ASK VERONICA TO
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION. WELL, WE
GOT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. I
THINK THAT'S GOOD. SO WE JUST
WANT CLARITY IN TERMS OF A DOJ
CERTIFIED PROVIDER THAT IS
SERVING OFF BASE, WHICH WOULD BE
IN CALIFORNIA'S JURISDICTION. SO
WITH THIS BILL THAT WOULD THEN
CREATE THAT AMBIGUITY. SO IF YOU
CAN JUST SPEAK TO THAT, RIGHT,
SO D O D WILL MAINTAIN.
JURISDICTION AS FAR AS
RESPONSIBILITY NOW, IF THERE'S
ANY ISSUES WITH THE PROVIDER,
THE WOULD REPORT TO CHILD CARE
SERVICES AND THEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IF NEEDED. BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY AND I BELIEVE THE
ANALYSIS DOES SAY TO MAKE IT
CLEAR IT REFERENCES A SPECIFIC
FEDERAL REGULATION. AND SO I
THINK YOU SHOULD BE OKAY. YES
YES, THAT'S GREAT. SO, UM, SO IN
AN IN AN EVENT THAT THERE IS A,
UM THERE IS A DEFICIENCY
IDENTIFIED BY THE D O D. THEY
WOULD THEN REPORT TO LOCAL
POLICE AND THEN TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CORRECT. OKAY AND
THEN WHAT WOULD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO INSPECT AND INTERVENE
IN THAT SITUATION? I BELIEVE SO
I CAN FIND OUT FOR YOU AND LET
THE COMMITTEE STAFF KNOW. OKAY
YES, JUST FOR CLARITY. LIKE I
SAID, I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
BILL. WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS CLARITY SO THAT THE
STATE UNDERSTANDS THEIR
JURISDICTION. THAT MAKES SENSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MOVED BY SENATOR
KOBACH ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM. NINE. SB
1401 MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL, I ALVARADO GIL. I
KOBO BOAKYE BLAKE SPEAR SPEAR I
MENJIVAR RI WAHA. JUST QUICK
QUESTION. WE'RE ALSO ADDING JUST
A CLARIFICATION THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED THAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE WORKED ON RIGHT? THAT'S
AGREED NOT ADDING ANY AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY EXPRESSING TO THE AUTHOR.
CLARIFICATION. CLARIFICATION.
YES, I WAHAB, I THANK YOU.
THAT'S FIVE AND O IN THAT BILL
IS OUT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY
WE ARE NEARING OUR FINALE HERE
WITH SENATOR CHILA. BOG ITEM
NUMBER 10 SENATE BILL 1245 WHEN
YOU ARE READY, SENATOR, MOVE THE
BILL.
HMM.
JOBURG WHEN YOU ARE READY TO
PROCEED. WE ARE HERE TO LISTEN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS,
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, THE EXPANSION
OF FULL SCOPE MEDICAL, INCLUDING
IN HOME SUPPORT SERVICES,
ELIGIBILITY WILL ADD 34,000 I H
S S CASES, WITH THIS INCREASE IN
TO REDUCE PREEXISTING BARRIERS
TO SERVICES. IT IS NECESSARY TO
STREAMLINE THE HSS PROCESS TO
ENSURE MORE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
CAN RECEIVE CARE IN THEIR HOMES
TO OBTAIN A H S S A CLIENT MUST
FILL OUT AND HAVE A LICENSE.
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS SIGNED
FORM S O. C 873, WHILE CDSS
ALLOWS ESSENTIALLY ANY LICENSED
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL TO SIGN
OFF ON THE INITIAL FORM TO
OBTAIN HSS C. D S S ONLY ALLOWS
A LIMITED NUMBER OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS WHO SIGNED THE
ADDITIONAL FORM TO AUTHORIZE
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES.
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES ARE NON
MEDICAL SERVICES AND INDIVIDUAL
COULD PERFORM THEMSELVES IF NOT
FOR THEIR FUNCTIONAL LIMITATIONS
. THIS DISPARITY IN WHO CAN SIGN
THESE FORMS HAS LED TO
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN OBTAINING
NECESSARY SERVICES AS A CLIENT'S
PRIMARY HEALTH CARE PROVIDER,
MAYBE SOMEONE OTHER THAN A
POSITION SUCH AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE NURSE. 1245 STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR OBTAINING
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES BY ALIGNING
WHICH LICENSED HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS MAY SIGN THE FORM
TO OBTAIN PARAMEDICAL SERVICES
WITH THOSE WHO CAN ALREADY
AUTHORIZED SERVICES THROUGH HS S
TO BEGIN WITH. I COMMIT TO
TAILORING THE LESS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN SIGN THE
FORM AS THE COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDS. I ALSO COMMIT TO
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THOSE
WHO WISH TO SEE ELIGIBLE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS SIGNED THE FORM
WITHOUT THE DIRECTION OF
PHYSICIAN WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS MELISSA JACOBS.
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR SENIOR AND
ADULT SERVICES FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH US
TODAY. UM ABOUT TWO MINUTES TO
PRESENT NAME AND AFFILIATION IN
YOUR OPENING, PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS MELISSA JACOBS AND I
AM THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
SENIOR ADULT SERVICES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. IN HOME.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES, I JUST
ASKED, PROVIDES ASSISTANCE FOR
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING FOR
BASIC TO MEET BASIC NEEDS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AGED, BLIND
AND DISABLED THAT THEY CAN STAY
IN THEIR OWN HOME FOR AS LONG AS
THEY POSSIBLY CAN, AND AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO MORE COSTLY OUT
OF HOME CARE. IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. WE SERVE OVER 37,000. I
JUST ASKED RECIPIENTS. UM AND OF
THOSE, AND WE CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE 1000 APPLICATIONS FOR
EVERY MONTH AND OF THOSE MORE
THAN 4800 ARE ALSO RECEIVING
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES. UM
PARAMEDICAL SERVICES AS YOU
HEARD THE REQUIRE SKILLS TO
PROVIDE TASKS THAT SOMEBODY
COULD NORMALLY DO FOR THEMSELVES
, BUT FOR THEIR DISABILITY OR
IMPAIRMENT. UM AND THEY HELP
MAINTAIN THEIR HEALTH AND
WELLNESS WELL BEING ON THEIR OWN
. SOME EXAMPLES OF PARAMEDICAL
SERVICES INCLUDE ADMINISTRATION
OF MEDICATIONS, SUCH AS AN
INFLUENCE INJECTION OR GLUCOSE,
MONITORING OR HELP WITH FEEDING
VIA A G TUBE OR SUPPORT WITH
TOILET NG VIA COLOSTOMY OR
CATHETER USE. UM PARAMEDICAL
SERVICES. UH, INCOME ENCOMPASS
ABOUT 40 HOURS ON AVERAGE, UH,
OF SERVICE TASKS FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL PER MONTH. UM IN
SACRAMENTO. IT CAN TAKE UP TO 45
DAYS FOR US TO RECEIVE THE
PARAMEDICAL FORM THAT'S COMPLETE
AND SIGNED. UM AND SO THAT MEANS
AN INDIVIDUAL FORGOES THOSE MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES OR A CARE
PROVIDER IS HAVING TO PROVIDE
THOSE TASKS WITH THEM NOT BEING
PAID. AND ALTHOUGH WE CAN
RETROACTIVELY PAY FOR THOSE
SERVICES IT IS CREATED, UM,
BURDEN AND REDUNDANCY FOR THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND STAFF WHO ARE
HAVING TO GO BACK INTO A CASE
FILE AND AUTHORIZED SERVICES
AUTHORIZED ADDITIONAL SERVICES
AND DOCUMENT THAT NEED HAVING
THE SAME LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL WITHIN THEIR SCOPE
OF PRACTICE, BE ABLE TO SIGN
BOTH THE HEALTH CERTIFICATION
FORM AND THE PARAMEDICAL FORM.
AT THE SAME TIME PROVIDES SOME
EFFICIENCIES FOR STAFF AND
SOCIAL WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO
APPROVE UNAUTHORIZED ALL OF
THOSE IN HOME. SUPPORTIVE
SERVICE TASKS HOURS AT THE SAME
TIME, WHICH THEN OBVIOUSLY
PROVIDES MORE SEAMLESS SUPPORT
TO OUR RECIPIENTS. AND SO WITH
THAT, I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SP
1245. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON, AMANDA
KIRK FROM CWD, A HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME. I WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS AT
THAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE WILL OPEN
IT UP TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
NAME AFFILIATION AND, UM
POSITION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NATUROPATHIC
DOCTORS ASSOCIATION, AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DILLONLIAM RASHAYA
ANSARI SCHMELZER AND LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF FRESNO
CURRENT SALARY AND HUMBOLDT ON
SPORT. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OF
RIVERSIDE AND VENTURA COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AMY WESTLING
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING, DANIEL BRADLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JEFF NEAL,
ON BEHALF OF THE BUDGET
SUPERVISOR AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN YOLO COUNTY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH RIGHT?
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
WILL WANTING TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE SEEN NONE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. HOLD
ON. LOOK AT THAT. COME ON.
QUESTION SENATOR MENJIVAR,
PLEASE. AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
SENATOR JOAB. SENATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH. I'M ALWAYS A BIG FAMILY
REMOVE, UM, BARRIERS RIGHT
EXPANDABLE HERE, BUT JUST AND I
APOLOGIZE. I MIGHT HAVE MISSED
IT IN THE BEGINNING. DID YOU
COMMIT TO CLARIFYING AND
NARRATING? I KNOW THE ANALYSIS
SAID THAT EVEN LIKE MANICURES OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE AS A LANGUAGE IS
WRITTEN. WE ARE. YES WE ARE
LIMITING THE QUESTION THE
LANGUAGE TO THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED. AND BUT I'M TRYING TO
SEE IF I HAVE THAT FOR YOU.
ACTUALLY WE'VE ONLY FOR THE
SERVICES. WHO CAN? I MEAN, IT'S
ONLY FOR THE PEOPLE WHO CAN SIGN
THE FORM FORM. BUT DO WE DO WE
KNOW WE DID. BUT YOU? YEAH BUT
YOU ARE YOU DID. WE'RE WORKING
TO MAKE SURE I BUY HER LIKE,
OKAY. WE'RE WORKING ON THAT.
SORRY. I HAD TO REALLY READ MY
NOTES. HERE. THANKS, SENATOR.
WHAT HAPPENED? THANK YOU. SO I
KNOW SENATOR. I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY WITH YOU AS WELL. UM AND
I KNOW I'VE TALKED TO YOU. SO I
JUST WANT TO LIKE, UH, REPHRASE
THIS PUBLICLY. AH I TRULY TRULY
SUPPORT I H S S WORKERS. I THINK
THAT THEY ARE INCREDIBLY VITAL
TO A LOT OF DISENFRANCHISED AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, I ALWAYS TRY TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HSS WORKERS TO BECOME AN
HSS, UM INDIVIDUAL THAT THE
BARRIERS INCREDIBLY LOW RIGHT.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT BEING
THAT LARGELY IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, PEOPLE THAT DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH, UM AND MUCH MORE
OFTEN RELY ON A FAMILY MEMBER OR
LOVED ONE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE
THAT CARE RANGES FROM A COUPLE
HOURS A WEEK TO LITERALLY ALL
DAY MOST DAYS RIGHT IN THE WEEK
AND I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT ONE.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT
. AND THEN NUMBER TWO THAT THIS
IS SPECIFICALLY ALLOWING FOR, UM
MORE INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
JUST SIGN ON AND SAY WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO. SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS IN THAT SENSE
EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST MENTIONED.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
PROVIDERS AT ALL JUST HAS TO DO
WITH THE ABILITY FOR, UH MORE
EXPANDED. UM, LEVEL OF. PEOPLE
WHO CAN ACTUALLY SIGN THOSE
FORMS TO GET THE SERVICES THAT
THE INDIVIDUALS NEED NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE PROVIDERS WHATSOEVER
. SO YES, YOU ARE CORRECT.
PERFECT I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOU
KNOW ATTENTION ON THIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR CHOU
BOGUE. YOU DIDN'T MAKE MENTION
TO THE LETTER OF OPPOSITION THAT
WAS SUBMITTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION NURSE PRACTITIONERS.
THEY HAD SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE,
AND IT SOUNDED FROM YOUR
PRESENTATION THAT YOU ARE
WILLING TO CONSIDER THAT YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THEM. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THANK YOU
ALSO FOR YOUR WITNESSES THAT ARE
BEING HERE TODAY. BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WAHA ASSISTANT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I'M SORRY.
PLEASE CLOSE. I JUST ASKED FOR
AN IPHONE. ALRIGHT ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT? BIO ITEM.
10 SP 1245 MOTION IS DUE PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALVARADO GIL. I ALVARADO GIL. I
KOBO. I LIKE SPEAR. SPEAR. I
MENTION FAR FAR I WAHA HA! BY
THE VOTE IS 5 TO 0 AND THAT BILL
IS OUT. SO BEFORE YOU LEAVE FOR
DINNER, WE'RE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL. RIGHT ASSISTANT. IF YOU
CAN CALL, UM, CALENDAR? YEAH
CONSENT CALENDAR, PLEASE. HMM
FILE ITEM FIVE FILE ITEM SIX ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, HOB HOB. I
OKAY? THAT'S 50. THAT VOTE IS
OUT, UM SENATE BILL 1016. WHAT
YOU DO IS ADOPTED BECAUSE I'M
SORRY. CONSENT IS ADOPTED. AND
THAT VOTE IS ALSO OUT. THANK YOU
HAVE TWO MORE FILE NUMBER ONE
SENATE BILL 1016. OKAY. SOUNDS
GREAT KOBO. OH, ITEM NUMBER ONE
SENATE BILL 1016 LIFTING THE
CALL. OH, THAT'S RIGHT. OKAY SO
THAT IS FOR EYES AND 01
ABSTAINED SO THAT VOTE IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE SENATE BILL
1249 ROTH KOBO CHILD BUG. AYE.
OKAY FIVE. IT'S FIVE OR NO, THAT
BILL IS OUT. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE SENATE BILL 1254 BECKER.
THAT I CALL THAT VOTE OUT.
HIGHLIGHT UM I'M SORRY. I LET
HIM FOR SENATE BILL 12541 MAKE
SURE I CALLED IT OUT. YES ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, UM SENATE BILL
1107. I REMEMBER TO JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE I CALLED THAT VOTE
OUT. YES THAT ONE'S OUT. WE JUST
SIT THERE. OKAY WONDERFUL. OKAY
RECOVER EVERYTHING. YEP. ALRIGHT
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH. EVERYONE
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR STAYING THANK YOU
FOR OUR CONSULTANTS AND ALL THE
WORK THAT OUR STAFF DOES IN OUR
OFFICE TO GET US TO THIS GREAT
PLACE AND TO OUR WONDERFUL
SERGEANTS COMMITTEE AND SAID IT
HUMAN SERVICES IS NOW ADJOURNED.